Oh, go shit.
Sorry.
My food's here.
I just, I just got the food.
I just got the food.
Okay.
No more loops.
I, the guy was lost.
I don't know how he lost, but he was lost.
I think I wrote the instructor.
Okay, so it's very hard to get inside my apartment building
because the security is tight.
In terms of like, you have to punch a code to get into my
building.
It's very tight security.
And the elevator is locked to a point where you either have
to have a fob like the little beeper thing that you have on
your key like you live there and it's linked to your floor
so basically I can't go to like some someone's a random
floor uh with my key like with my key basically so it's like
tight you know so like I don't have to worry about security
and everything um but I'm very step by step detailed
instructions on how to get into my building.
And I think the guy was very confused and didn't read my
step-to-step guide in my instructions.
Because also, the elevators are also linked to certain
floors.
Because at first, it was like a trial and error where every
time I realize a delivery person gets confused, I add in an
extra step in my instructions.
So the elevator is also linked to specific floors.
So one time, they would be like, oh, I couldn't get to your
floor because, like, the elevator wouldn't go to your floor.
So I was like, oh, I should put that in my instruction.
So I'd be like, step one, do this.
Step two, do that.
And then this guy was, was like, I think it was, like,
outside my apartment building, trying to figure out how to
get past the first step because he didn't read.
He didn't read my instructions.
But he made it.
He made it.
He got there.
I got the call.
I got the call where they're like, we're outside.
I need the I need the the entry you know like when they call
you on the intercom and then you on your phone You go beep
and you let them in like we I need you to let me in and shit
like that.
Okay, so Um, I tried yeah, tried to decipher my anyway, I
got jolly bees.
Yeah, I was craving jolly bees Yesterday, but then I had
leftover pizza from two days ago.
So I was like I should really eat my leftover pizza.
I didn't want to waste my food.
So I was just like, oh, I really I really should eat my
pizza that I ordered two days ago.
So I have jolly bees, and I think the guy did not get me a
straw.
Let me double check because I did ask for utensils.
But I feel like straws are not part of my utensils.
I once had a delivery guy.
I had the instruction because I, you know, I don't want to
go downstairs because I'm wearing pajamas.
Um, I once, oh, oh, there is a straw.
There's a straw.
There is no fork.
You know, I got my straw.
at least sometimes they don't give me a straw so at least at
least i got this i don't have a fork dog i asked for
utensils i guess utensils mean just the straw uh um is your
apartment from the maze runner mr broken body the super chat
thank you thank you delivery uh mr my fluffikins thank you
for the super chat at least i got my straw so you know it's
the little things in life I got the straw like I got one of
the other it's either I get a straw or I get a fork you know
and at least I don't have straws at home by the way I don't
I don't have the stainless steel straws or whatever or the
paper like a fucking stockpile of paper straws um because I
also I really hate paper straws but that's the world we live
in now um despite like millionaires taking jet plane rides
every fucking day like when the super bowl ended and then
like 80 80 plus planes flew out of wherever the fuck the
super bowl was that day but my my plastic straw was so much
worse uh my plastic and paper straws are your devil
incarnate apparently worse than jet fuel um
I remember I remember we talked about like what 100 plus
planes left San Francisco the moment the super like 100 not
public planes by the way 100 plus private planes left San
Francisco but oh my paper shop was Satan himself um um uh
I'm not reading all that happy for you sorry it happened
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh crystal
crystal thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
cold pizza hot pizza the next day i i do not with cold pizza
i'm sorry for all the cold pizza enjoys i just if like i
have a microwave why would i like not use this like just 30
seconds of my life i just don't like it has cheese on it
like why the would i want cold cheese on the pizza.
I'd rather have it with hot melted cheese.
Like, boo.
I just don't... I don't know.
I feel like, you know, if it's pizza, I would eat the hot
pizza with the hot melted cheese instead of the cold pizza,
where the cheese is hard and not melted.
All right, let me go grab my...
uh wooden fork uh i mean i do have a steel fork but i don't
also i don't fuck with like steel straws because it has like
this weird ass aftertaste with the straw this like the
metals taste like and i just you know i i'd rather just
drink paper you know so yeah let me grab my wooden fork i'll
be right back not plastic though not plastic because i think
about the turtles
all right we're gonna eat a little bit before i I know I'm
I'm back at it in Overwatch I'm I'm back I'm I'm I'm back
with I know I know I went from one addiction to I was like
ah yay vacation anyone let's go back in hit it up let's
let's go back into the mines you know since I'm eating I
might as well be here I might as well well dead chat
somehow let me let's see there we go all right the addiction
continues let me eat a little bit and then i need a little
bit of food in me before we go back to hell um so yeah now i
got addicted again to overwatch um because uh when they
introduced the five okay i not it wasn't until i got back
from vacation where i was just like first thing i do after
coming back from vacation is to do overwatch uh let's go
back to my old ways by the way i know i said i did promise a
monday uh a monday stream um and uh the thing is i when i
was at vacation also wait let me just do one chop before i
go because i know i'm gonna talk like for like 30 minutes
the mukbang asmr for you um i love jolly bees oh my god i
got the half and half so i like half spicy and half non like
original and spicy chicken so it's like one one one of each
um the way i say oh yeah when i was on vacation i did not do
any work um it was really bad i was on vacation vacation i
did not do anything i did not respond to anything which was
bad because i'm that's like monday i was like i was playing
catch up with everything i missed out They're really like,
um, and also my sleep is very fucked right now.
Um, that's a poor vacation, but the thing is, oh my god,
it's cold.
I gotta take too long, bring my food.
But the thing is, you just think like the world stops when I
stop, but the world continues on.
So, so there's a lot of like, you know, contracts and like,
like events and like obligation that keeps continuing on.
lies for it to continue on so they're like where the fuck is
dokey bird and
like life goes on it's crazy i know i mean i was like um i
stopped working what do you mean you all continued working
like what do you mean you need my reply so that we're not
behind
so um yeah how dare the world So there was a lot of stuff I
had to like catch up on.
So that's why Monday it was, I wanted to, but the
responsible person in me was like, you got to, you have to
catch like you have to respond to these people or you're
fucked.
And I was like, oh, shit, maybe, maybe I should respond to
these people.
And then also I played a little bit of Overwatch yesterday
too.
Simple mind.
I have my priorities, right?
Thank you.
Super chat.
They'll get probably better.
You don't use paper straws.
It gives all the turtles something to use.
Simple to use a super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't get everything done.
I did get like, you know, I tackled the workload, you know.
I attempted to tackle it.
But, and then also my sleep is really fucked up right now.
I won't say, I don't know if it's, I don't think it is.
How's your Pokopia village going on?
Well, it was going on fine.
They like, they asked for me things.
minimum because like i for me pokepil was just me
interacting people i didn't care about like how pretty my
town looks or anything like or how you know the aesthetic of
the town i just they're like i want this and i was like here
take it you know i just chucked down a wooden shack and be
like that's your new home now like that's that would be five
thousand dollars a month um and and then i go on twitter and
i see people build like the fucking recreation of like the
subway and like a recreation of like fucking pallet town and
everything and i'm just like oh
oh take your yeah take your outdoor bush house like i'm like
a little slum yeah and i saw some people create recreate the
fucking roman empire you see that's why i enjoyed animal
crossing before i was like terminally online you know like
when COVID happened during like the the the animal like when
COVID like when COVID happened when everyone was spamming
Animal Crossing but before then I was enjoying Animal
Crossing nobody really cared much about Animal Crossing like
damn people did care it wasn't until COVID happened where
everyone's like oh they were all like shut in they're all
like you know you'll find Elijah Wood on Twitter asking for
his favorite villagers or for like stock market or shit like
the stock market turnips And then people were creating like
actual like like recreated Tokyo and at an animal crossing
And that's when I stopped playing animal crossing because
then I I was just like I can't dare for him I was like I
can't do any of this I can't I'm just like I can't I'm sorry
I'm so I'm a terrible Fucking mayor I'm I'm fucking terrible
at me I'm sorry My villagers, all I want to do is fish and
go to islands and Pick up funny fruits and do random and go
to a forest like and dig up fossils I don't fucking want to
design anything.
I don't want to tear up for him.
I Don't care what happens.
I just want to I want to do my mayor responsibility
I haven't been playing much Poképiea.
I will be brutally honest.
I have not played much Poképiea after that.
I was like, here's how it looks.
I don't know.
Dude, I saw someone build like a mansion for their Pokemon.
And I was just like, how?
They built like a fucking wooden log.
I got nothing I saw I like I think I bookmarked it I saw
someone build like a wooden lodge for their Pokemon and they
were like so upset that their Pokemon didn't like the house
I was like I'll move in I'll fucking I'll fucking move in
and that Pokemon doesn't want it I was like here here's a
build a functioning someone has built a functioning subway
station in in and I was like that's like insane that's
actually crazy and free housing in this economy I'll fucking
move in there like that Pokemon oh yeah and then someone I
bookmarked all of this because even I was like what the fuck
someone built a um built a working calculator in Pocopia
it's like they basically Minecraft this shit they like read
they figure out the redstone mechanics in Pokapia, so now
you have a functioning calculator in the game.
Fuck, fuck using your, fuck using a Google calculator or
your phone.
Here's a, here's a goddamn Pokapia, um, calculator.
What the fuck?
I know.
That shit's crazy.
So now my Pokemon's living in the goddamn slums.
I didn't customize anything.
and they like it that way by the way they like it that way
they don't know what's better for them thank god they don't
know they don't know the world outside of my switch too
thank fucking god i'm not a lie
what else what else oh yeah also monday another reason why i
didn't stream on monday was that I was hanging out with
Sachi.
I asked her if I could tell this story, because I thought it
was really funny.
I was hanging out with Sachi yesterday.
And did you, I wanted, I asked her if I could talk about
this part, because I was just like, I was just like, you
know, we were catching up and stuff, because,
because, oh, by the way, her dog's doing great right now.
Her dog's recovering.
She's doing great.
yesterday or today's Tuesday yesterday yesterday uh I was
just talking over hanging out um and um and it was crazy
like uh hanging out discord and I was just like she was like
did you know I'm in gotcha life and I was like what she told
this story before she's like yeah I mentioned it before but
it was crazy and she was like yeah and then she like screen
shared like gotcha life to me gotcha like but her her her
like original character like the pink hair girl is in gotcha
life like because like apparently the creator of gotcha life
is like a huge artist fan and like asked her was like oh can
i like include your this was years ago if i conclude your
character in gotcha life so you boot up gotcha life that
pink hair girl that's her and then you can find her on the
beach and it was so funny she just says whale facts by the
way yeah her name is mumble the girl's name is mumble and
then you can find her in the beach and all she says is just
whale facts she was like spamming it and she's like yeah and
it's just like i love whales it's like save the whales did
you know whales blah blah blah it's like because she's like
that's all she said she just gives you fucking whale pack.
It's so fucking funny.
Um, it's so silly.
There's like a bunch of people on there.
Like a bunch of like old school artists.
And she's like, yeah, that's how she got.
Apparently that's how she got like a million subscribers on
her old channel.
Um, because like all the like kids found her like found her
via gotcha life and like followed her on YouTube because of
it.
Cause you're like, oh my god, that's her.
That's mumble.
Um, she says she gained a lot of subscribers just from
gotcha life
yeah so you find you can find a lot of like the original
like the and like what's it called the youtube animation
animation memes a lot of the famous back then youtube
animation memes come from um are actually in gotcha life
yeah that is wild
what else oh yes I wanted to tell you guys about this um but
I I was gonna show it to you guys after after like you know
I was gonna show it to you guys today because I was like oh
yeah I'm gonna unpack but obviously I did it I think that
she thinks she is she's gonna unpack it's so fucking funny
you know she's not gonna unpack it's gonna be like one to
two months and then she'll finally unpack her suitcase
because then she has to travel again it has to chunk
everything that's so silly like she's so naive to think
she's gonna actually unpack she's so optimistic i feel like
i always unpack whenever i have to travel again
anyway um so for those pigmen i was like debating how to how
to this but for my pigment you guys for pigment enjoyers
they'll know this meme but I found the homophobic dog in
pigment I've never played was it pigment for I've never
played pigment for before but I know all about the
homophobic dog I found him yeah I found him I got the plush
I was like I think I was him.
We were at a store.
I was like, oh my god, it's the homophobic dog.
I was like, I must have it.
Not because he's homophobic, because it's...
Not because he's homophobic, but I thought it's funny.
It's...
How'd him?
So now I own...
Now I own the homophobic dog from Pickman, because I...
Because I thought it was really, yes, it's as.
Like, let me show you guys what he's, for those who are not
Pikmin and George, they're like, what the fuck is she
talking about?
It's actually my search history.
This is the,
the, what dog?
So I now own a plushie.
I don't even know his name.
That's the, by the way, it was monsters of shit.
typist oh my god it's mine i didn't even know his name i
just know him as the
that's him yeah that's him so i had to get him not because
he's homophobic because he looked really funny and then also
cuts out the memes about it so now now i legally own moss
the dog uh he knows what you are he didn't know this yeah i
saw this i saw this meme um i saw this meme everywhere when
uh when when the game first came out and people were like um
i forgive
and people like moustache well he's not homophobic stop
saying that and then maybe don't have the which side are you
on which yeah so um so i now i didn't buy the other dog
because it's not as funny i i had to get that dog i i think
judgmental stare goes right into my soul.
Anyway, also, other than that, other than that, oh yeah, I
forgot to tell this story.
I forgot to tell this story.
But when I met Kenny, he was like, he didn't know much about
VTubers.
I told him about how, because he was like very surprised.
I forgot to tell this story, but he was very surprised when
I posted that tweet of the picture that he took with like
the mini-dote he's um he was like oh my god i didn't realize
there's so many wrestling fans uh uh with vtube like in
vtubing like in the vtubing community and he was like it was
so cool to see like so many people recognizing me like he
was reading the replies off that tweet by the way guys so he
saw you guys by the way he saw you guys so he was reading
the tweets um from that like the replies from that tweet and
he was like oh my god i didn't realize there was so many
like um wrestling stuff and he thought it was really really
cool so if you like replied to that tweet he saw you he saw
he acknowledged you guys um he saw me yeah kenny read your
tweets jack goons um um noel thank you for the 20 gift of
chips thank you thank you uh and yeah i was telling him yeah
there's like a surprise like a huge amount of overlap and
everything and it was so cool um it's so cool me And then,
like, you know, after he left on Sunday, he, like, DMed me
on Twitter, being saying, like, how it was so cool to meet
me and stuff, and, like, like, hope, like, our paths crossed
again and stuff like that.
He's such a nice guy.
Like, the fact that he even DMed me, right, like, after he
left Japan, and then he's like, oh, enjoy the rest of your
trip and also have a safe flight, too, and he's just, it was
just pretty cool for him to do.
But anyway, that's all the stuff.
um that's everything i really uh wanted to talk about um
it's overwatch time yes i am back on the overwatch grind um
i'm a little bit and i won't say like super addicted i just
like seeing my rank number go i'm i'm very washed by the way
i'm i like i was i was so i've been asking friends on like
how the new meta is by the way kiriko i did buy the near
skin for kiriko because like i have no skins over Kiriko and
I'm sorry but like I'm tired of seeing Kiriko's default skin
and like I know she gets everything she gets everything guys
and like I know I'm I'm part of the I'm I'm I'm part of the
system by encouraging more by buying a Kiriko skin um but I
was just so tired I was that guy on Overwatch thank you very
welcome to tomato I'm buying the problem.
I'm adding to the problem by purchasing her skin.
But like, I literally have zero Kiriko skins.
And I was so fucking tired of seeing her dumb, dumb ass
default skin.
Uh, with that, with that, like at least the nearest skin
covers her face.
Like, I was just so tired to see her red outfit and
everything.
And so, yeah, I only see, you only see her answer, not when
I'm winning or losing.
What did she mean by this?
Isachi, she is unfortunately not addicted to the, like, any,
to Overwatch anymore.
But I've been trying to convince her to play Overwatch with
me.
Not on stream, but, like, you know, off stream.
Anyway, what was I going to say?
And then when I see kill camps, I see myself.
I was just like, that's stupid bitch.
But like, I have to play Kiriko.
I have to play her.
Because now I understand why.
Apparently she's been meta for like 10 plus seasons.
So like you have to play her.
Like if you don't play her, you fucking lose.
So it's like she's like hard meta right now.
She's like hard, hard meta.
like she's just too good and i've been yeah she's been meta
since her release so that's why she gets everything uh and
i'm a meta slave anyway i'm super fucking washed uh i
haven't played this game in a while and uh and like i'm so
bad at aiming with kiriko i will let you guys i got yelled
at by my i got yelled at yesterday by somebody because
they're like you have this x amount of damage What the fuck
are you doing on Kiriko?
And I'm like, I'm a second pick.
You didn't want to play Kiriko.
Like, how do you only do this much damage?
I'm just like, I don't know how to aim on Kiriko.
I'm sorry.
I just came back.
So, um, no, her, her projectiles are so hard to aim.
I fuck jetpack cat has banned every game and like the moment
the enemy team goes alari say goodbye to the cat I literally
enemy team had we didn't ban jetpack cat and one game they
didn't ban jetpack cat and then um um and then like my
friend was like just play alari if the enemy team goes
jetpack cat I went alari and because and I went alari I just
shot that cat out of the sky and then they insta-swapped.
I just, I headshot the cat.
Like, I literally just killed him one time.
I saw him kill them one time.
And then he swapped off because he's like, yep, I see how
that goes.
I get...
So that's how you counter the cat, apparently.
It worked.
It actually works.
He was like, I'm not dealing with that.
Get shot one time.
And it's like, I'm done.
Another human.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki, I'm sending you part of my first paycheck ever.
Tell you that you're my goat and to wish you.
Thank you.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you so much for the support and your very first
paycheck.
Oh, my God.
Congratulations.
I'm so happy for you.
Yay.
Dominique.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome.
Anyway, so, um, so, yeah, we're going to be playing
Overwatch.
My, I know I'm washed.
I, I know, guys, I've, I, I've been playing for a while and,
and I know.
So, uh, I've been playing the last few days and I was like,
oh my god, all these new, I can't, I was so frustrated at
myself because, um, I think I could get back into it.
Like, I'm still, I'm getting better, but I'm trying.
I'm getting better every day.
I'm getting better every day, like, getting back into the
game.
Because they changed so many things.
They changed so many things in how, like, like, everything,
like, what I've learned back in the day to what it is now is
so different.
It's like, it takes a while to get back into and shaking off
the rust.
But yeah, no, Kiriko projectile is like no other projectiles
I've ever played.
Like, I've ever, like, shot before.
I never touched Kiriko when a game first launched.
I didn't even have, I bought the gold gun, by the way.
The moment I bought that nearest, I didn't, I realized,
because I was like, oh, I get gold guns for every support I
play.
But Kiriko was like the one character I didn't have a gold
gun for.
Other than like Jetpack had like the new characters that
just came in, like Wu Yang and Mizuki.
And Kiriko was literally like the one, the one support back
in the game.
in the old days, I didn't have a gold gun for it because I
refused to play Kiriko.
like, I hated playing, look, I got I got the Nier skin.
Um, I hated playing Kiriko and I refused to play her back
then, even though she was meta.
I would play everything but Kiri.
And so, like, anyway, I got her Nier skin because I didn't,
I was so tired.
Look, I have three skins.
Like, I actually only have three.
You have to understand why I was so tired of seeing this
default skin.
I was fucking tired sorry dear to be um i was so i don't i
never played the year before but i was like i was so fucking
tired of seeing this default skin and seeing her smug-ass
face looking at me because i had to keep playing kiriko and
and then the only thing i was not gonna put the hina tori
skin that skin is ugly and then the other one was like oh
she's orange she's what's right when you've seen the skin
every time you just get i'm just i was just like i'm So
tired.
So I was like, I have to get another skin.
I was just so tired of seeing that goddamn skin that I had
to like get something like That's all the skin she has that
was just I I had to see like something Look at look at all
all the skin she has and I only have like These are the only
ones I own like what if Kierkegaard was All right That's how
much I'm like, how I did not give a fuck about Kiriko.
I, but, but now, now I have to.
Yeah, now I have to because she's meta and I'm trying to
grind right now.
Um, like, look at, look at all the stuff I don't have.
Like, I don't even have, I have none of her highlight
intros, guys.
By the way, look at this.
None of her highlight intros.
Um, let's see.
Check all, check all.
all look at that wait i said check oh wait all right here
you go none of her highlight inch oh i do have kitsune rush
but then i realize she has a lot sorry none of her i only
have two of this two out of 14 why where does this how do i
filter everything like how do i see every oh check all is it
this does that give me everything oh yeah cosmetics I have
on Kiriko like three out of 89 two out of 14 four out of 20
three out of my default I don't even have a victory pose
that's how little I cared it's like don't even I just
realized I don't even have oh wait let's get that one of
course I don't even have a victory pose um five out of 36
and then look at and then do I have more on oh yeah Juno
asks I got a Juno the Gold gun before I even had a Kiriko
gold gun.
That's how little I cared about her.
That's I actually got a Juno gold gun and she came out long
after Kiriko.
I only bought the Kiriko gold gun yesterday.
I literally bought it yesterday because one of my friends
was like, wait, you don't have the Kiriko gold gun?
I was like, no, I do.
See her weapon.
Her weapon is right because I couldn't tell you're like no
that's not gold I was like I must have that gold gun there's
no way I did it I looked at I was like wait I actually don't
have a gold gun cuz look I have gold gun on Juno not cat
gold gun on Ellari gold wait do I have gold gold on Brigham
gold on Bap I even have gold on Bap gold on Anna gold on Zen
not Wien gold on Gold on Mercy, but I refuse to put it on
because like there's implications if I put it on.
Gold on Lucio.
Gold on.
Wait, not Lifeweaver because also like I don't give a fuck
about playing like I don't like if I feel like Lifeweaver is
like people play Lifeweaver if Mercy is banned.
So they just go to Lifeweaver because it's like a similar.
It's like similar mechanics.
So I didn't put on Lifeweaver too.
It's like, if I get Life Weaver, I wouldn't even put it on
because it's a similar implications to Mercy.
Because the moment I put a gold, look, this is, the moment
you put a gold gun on Mercy, they'll be like, oh, you're a
Mercy, you mean, aren't you?
You're a Mercy one trick, aren't you?
Oh, yeah, Women on Mercy with the gold gun.
So then I refused to put it on.
So then people are like, oh, she doesn't have a gold gun.
She must not actually play Mercy.
So then I was like, there you go.
So that's why I don't do it.
Yeah.
And so people also don't throw my game too.
They throw less likely to throw if you don't have a gold gun
on your mercy.
But yeah, anyway, so I don't.
But yeah, doesn't everyone have gold guns on everyone?
Yes, but then if I don't have a gold gun on mercy, then
they'll be like, oh, she doesn't play.
She's not a mercy man.
You know, you know, it's like 4D chess, you know, you're
you're playing with layers They're like oh, she's playing
mercy, but she doesn't mean mercy like Because they don't
all she doesn't have a gold gun on her that means she
doesn't mean her like
But yes, and then I was blown I couldn't believe that I
didn't actually didn't have a fucking gold gun on Kiriko
after all I even have a gold gun on soldier and I don't
Soldier and Tracer and Cassidy, but set no gold gun on Kiri
for, until yesterday, until yesterday.
Until yesterday, so I was just like, holy fuck, I never
cared.
All I've been doing this season has been, I've just been
spamming Kiriko.
Let's see.
Also, I'm so sad because I suck at, I suck at Lucio now.
lucio again but like i i've been pretty bad at lucio i i
will admit i've been pretty fucking bad at lucio um but all
i've been playing has been like i've been trying i'm trying
to learn i swear to god yes okay wait let me show you guys
all competitive i've been i've been trying to learn i've
been trying to learn here right now um literally like since
overwatch this is like Overwatch 2 is me trying to figure
out Kiriko.
Try to remember it out.
Because, like, her projectile, her projectile is, like, so
different from any other character I've played in, like, my
entire FPS career.
It's so different.
Like, the speed and, like, the way she, like, the way her
projectile works is just so different.
so hard to like get it in my head um no zen is so much
easier zen projectile is a lot easier to aim with it's a lot
it's a bit faster than um it's a bit oh what's this i
thought oh yeah you guys notice it okay so but you can
change i i found out okay it's an accessibility you can make
your fucking cursor fucking huge like cursor fucking huge so
this is default it's like it's 120 it doesn't it doesn't
show up in game i just thought it was funny i just i'll
never lose it you know it just it's just in the main menu i
just i'll never lose it like i'll know where it is and i'm
looking for it
What if I would put it, what if I need, what if I forgot, I
don't like this, I would say I don't like this mythic skin.
Because, like, all the other mythic skins look so fucking
cool.
And, like, I feel like this is more of a, this mythic skin
looks more like a, um, looks more like a store skin.
Because every other mythic skin that everyone has, I feel,
looks a lot cooler.
Like, it looks more badass and stuff.
And, um, so I don't really like the May one very much.
um anyway the skills are cool i just don't like the the look
of it i like the um i like the by the way the 2b skin was
the only skin i've ever bought from the store i've never
bought anything i actually never bought anything like with
my real with real ass money i never bought anything else the
2b one was the only one i paid for i think i used my legacy
coins for it like my Yeah, my, my, uh, Overwatch coins or
something.
I don't even know.
I don't remember.
I didn't actually spend real money.
It was for my legacy coins from Overwatch 1.
Um, I don't know.
I just don't, I don't fuck with the, with the, the, the look
of it.
Um, maybe like the cosmetics look like not cosmetic, but the
ability and stuff look cool.
But I just, I don't, I think like the other, especially
right after Mercy too, like that skin looks beautiful right
after Mercy.
And like, that skin is actually beautiful so it's just like
i just don't really like it as much after coming right after
the mercy one um anyway anyway all right so yeah someone's
like go play dps i have been queuing dps as well so i think
that's i don't know that's master or diamond i think master
five dps master five tank and then master one support i'm
not gonna solo queue i'm gonna do like
I mean I'd rather do it I don't want to like if I'm gonna
suffer I always I want to like drag someone down with me
all right all right let's queue up if I'm losing like I also
I told I told him I told him if we fucking lose that support
get on your main role because we're I'm gonna I I'm gonna
lose, I'd rather lose Elo on our main roles.
I,
I'd rather, yeah, I'd rather, yeah, I'd like to get on them.
Anyway, let's fucking play.
Oh yeah, um, what else?
Um, I am getting better.
I am getting better.
day no two days ago was like your kiri's carrying you and i
was like that's me that's me i have 800 damage but that's i
have 800 damage but that's me
800 hey you said i was carrying he's saying he said i was
carrying taking I'm getting better I'm getting better at it
okay that's me you're not supposed to you're supposed to
have at least above a thousand damage um um on Keri because
you're not supposed to be heel botting and like that's like
my issue because I think it's also like Marvel Rydos has
made me be more made me like heel bot too much on certain
characters so um the Kiri is carrying the game has so
because i did overwatch damage is so important like doing
damage as a support um is so important um so uh uh so like
it's like a mindset i have to like get back into
i think overwatch is harder than rivals 100 as a support
player only because like you don't you don't live as long
and your ults are mostly like damage looks and not like i
live forever
also nobody knows me in overwatch too everyone is like
everyone's very raw
everyone is like if you're bad they'll call you out
yeah overwatch a healer in overwatch is more than just
supporting your supporting oh i was like my chicken i was
eating the crunchy part of my chicken but now i can't eat
anymore because i actually have to lock in yeah
no but nobody like i don't think i haven't had anyone
recognize me in overwatch yet since i've came back to
playing all right i guess i'll play kiri i have to get
better at kiri
why not 6v6 nobody plays 6v6 i'll find my own
Nobody plays 6v6.
What's the current rank master one?
We're going straight into I don't know about hit GM It could
happen either I do rate.
Holy shit never Never mind reset the clock reset
Reset the timer The first time someone I've been playing a
lot guys.
That's crazy.
I've been I've been playing the last three days has
recognized me and the first my first game the first game
someone was like oh my literally don't want to set that damn
you're right i forgot okay all right watch me get headshot
all right don't worry i'll be here i'll my teammates will be
okay right
My teammates will be okay.
He's fine.
There, I got the suzu.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll do damage eventually.
I just...
Oh, shit.
That's not good.
That's actually not good.
Alright.
Look, I'm not dead, though.
Not yet.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll do damage, right?
Here.
Starting here.
I'm working up to it.
Alright?
I'm working up to the damage portion.
See, look at that!
You saw that?
60.
I'm famous laugh.
I didn't get sniped, though.
I didn't get sniped.
Watch this.
Oh!
I got a hit.
Whoops, I should heal him.
Okay, I know how what to upgrade on Kiri.
There are some characters that actually don't know
Oh That'll be fine, right
That'll be fine Okay, all right my lorries got the other All
right, I have ults here I was just actually surprisingly not
a throw Surprisingly, I don't know if I should I should be
up there.
Look at that.
Ooh, saw that.
Another 60 right there.
Yeah.
Boom!
This might not be a good ult, but I trust my team.
That might not be a good ult.
Yeah.
Oh!
Whoops.
I hope he doesn't hit my team above.
Alright.
Oh my my god my lorry is so fucked oh oh everything is okay
not for him though oh fuck okay i was like what the fuck
where did that come from that's fine making sure he's okay
look at that don't worry i have the i technically i don't
need to do damage if i have the lorry to do it for me.
Think about that.
If you think about it, technically, I don't need to do
damage.
To be fair, Asola and Domina is fine.
She's so broken right now.
Apparently she's like hard meta at the moment.
Like, oh, I'm okay here.
So I don't mind.
Domina is just way too broken.
Her and Diva are like really hard meta.
Whoa, why are you coming for me?
I'm just a little jack.
Oh, I got you.
Oh, shit.
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'm okay.
We're gonna stop the payload.
Wait, where's the affair?
Hey, we stopped the payload.
Oh!
Look at that.
Like I said, I'm not very good at the aim department for
Kiriko, but I can, I sure can suzu.
I can suzu though.
I can,
I can, I can suzu guys.
I can suzu.
I'm very good at making sure my teammate lives.
Oh shit, you're not...
You're not on the high ground?
There you go.
That's fine.
Oh my god, me too.
Me too.
Nah, never mind.
Oh shit, four ults, let's go.
Okay, maybe...
Maybe that's a little too much.
No, apparently the movement is better.
Chills.
Oh yeah.
All right, four ults, four ults.
It doesn't matter.
We can farm it again.
No apparently, I was told that this is like what pro players
use for their...
Oh, oh, oh, you saw that?
Wait, no supports, no supports.
No shit.
Oh shit.
No, okay, wait.
No.
Wait, saw that, though.
Okay, that was sort of an ego peak right there.
I shouldn't have ego peak that I...
I will...
Why would you go left when we went right when we go left?
Oh, that's not good.
Wait, he's so low.
Oh my god, he's actually so low.
Now, movement speed apparently is better.
how what yeah me too yo what yeah me too um we got so pushed
back oh no i jinxed i jinxed it oh no please yeah see i can
get away with the suzu
okay it's fine it's fine it's just for First game, his first
game.
Oh, he definitely has all of them, though.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I'm safe here.
Oh my god.
I am no longer safe here.
I was safe for so long, though.
I will say, I was safe for a very long time.
It's okay.
I lived a lot longer than I should have.
It was...
I should not have lived for that long.
I will say that.
Alright, there we go.
I almost have a...
Our alt...
Our...
Oh, wait, there we go.
Our alt management is pretty bad.
That's okay.
We're all warming up.
Look at that.
I'm almost at a thousand damage, guys.
As long as I'm above a thousand damage, I take those.
I take those.
So how about that one kit?
Oh my god.
All right.
All right, it's okay.
Whoa.
Okay.
Let's hope everyone lives.
Oh.
I'll
be here on this side.
I'm okay with that.
Oh shit, I'm no longer okay with that.
I'm no longer.
It's not me, though.
It's not me.
I might have 900.
Simple.
thank you thank you is there any chance we could see it
toxedoki come out most likely on the second game you'd be
surprised uh most likely the second game it comes out faster
than you anticipate
all right let me grab
okay We got this on the second game.
The second half is where I wake up, guys.
You're going to see that thousand damage.
I hope so.
I hope you see that thousand damage on the second half.
Some more chicken, yeah, but then I have to fucking wash my
hands after.
Well, I have to actually just wipe my fingers after.
I just it's that.
Doss, what's going on?
Is he still?
Okay, he's not on Fara anymore at least, you know?
Damn, the call out.
It was my bad when I fucking Jesus Christ or Okay, oh my
gosh, all right, I'm not peaking that anymore.
All right, I'll stop peaking them, sorry.
There you go.
Look at that, that has to be a thousand.
That hit, yep, there you go.
There you go.
Jesus Christ, okay, it's fine.
Longer fine, I forgot there was another door there.
All right, it's my bad, I forgot there was a door.
It's okay, I have rank protection.
The thing about Overwatch is that you get 1 plus 1 before
you fully demote.
So I have... I could still be Master 1, technically.
Well, whatever.
I'll just use... Whatever.
Oh, God, he's looking for me.
actually looking for me oh my god I don't want to be here I
actually I don't know if I want to be here okay
I don't know my don't goodbye I can't even scissor that he
drags me in the air oh bring game up a little bit all right
don't worry I don't have a I don't have a choice I mean our
Hans is doing great it's just oh Jesus Christ every time I
peek I feel like I'm gonna die oh no oh no I use suzu I use
suzu I hope he's alive I hope he's alive there he is he is
he is he is he is so healthy he is so healthy right here not
though oh never mind he's no luck I do have a I do have a
look I just think those arena what's going on he's not in
chat it was like what's going on see I told you it's not me
it's not me guys I told you the heck he's like he's not in
chat bro.
He's not it's not just waste don't waste your breath He's a
lot of people surprised they don't go on chat.
No, no go on VC anymore I've noticed that at least we we got
out we got out of here Oh, yeah, look at that.
Oh, no, look at that Here we go.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, are you still there?
Oh, that headshot!
Alright, we gotta kill that guy.
I got a headshot in him.
Oh, what the fuck?
Come on, get me out of here.
Nice people join VC now, which I've noticed.
I've noticed that.
There you go.
That was a huge risk for me to go up there.
Woo!
Goodbye Goodbye All right, see you're so healthy.
Oh, don't look at me though
Whoa, okay Oh fuck All right, I don't think you'll live wait
unless Oh never mind No one less What the fuck?
Why are you so low?
Oh, I should not have left my Hanzo.
I should I'm sorry Hanzo What
That is that is crazy that he did that Oh my god that Hanzo
once me did Is he fine?
He's so healthy see.
He should be 5.
Oh my god.
I'm no longer 5.
Hey, look.
At least, D'Ocerino got two more kills.
You know?
That's all that matters.
He got two more kills.
Okay, we could kill him.
Yeah, I was gonna save.
Kill this guy.
Come on.
Oh!
Where?
What?
That doesn't even show up!
That's actually bullshit.
What the fuck?
Okay, that I would like to say that is bullshit, ma'am.
Wait, where's my Sigma?
Holy fuck, I'm so confused.
Like, where are we going?
It's like we're playing with the hard bot.
Where are we going?
Where are we...
I'm trying to figure out where to go.
There you go.
Does he live?
Oh, no.
All right.
Oh, my bad.
My bad.
Ebb-in-teen.
Oh, he's lost.
Oh, he lost.
Ebb-13 ended.
Oh, he's in bed.
terrorist stuff oh my lord just report him just report him
for terrorist activities oh no that's a guy that recognize
me that's a cat i recognize he said just report him just
report him for suspicious for these oh he doesn't want to
play support anymore he doesn't the guy that had the guy
that wait where was it see i got okay so it's or was it game
report oh
We claim it.
It's a guy that was on my team where I was saying like,
yeah, I haven't had anyone recognize me in Overwatch in the
last three days of playing.
And this was the first game, first guy that was like, oh my
God, is that Doki Bird?
And he was the first one.
Someone recognized you as a, you made a nervous Doki.
Ow, it just existed.
How did I make him...
He didn't have to say hi.
It was his choice to say hi.
All right.
What does future want to play?
I won't play Kiriko if...
If he doesn't play Kiri, I won't play Kiri.
I mean, if he plays Kiri, I won't play Kiri.
pick something come on pick something i can't tell what you
play no more come on pick something come on oh my god fine
like no you pick some okay fine i got above 1k though last
game let's go You're like, no, you.
You pick something.
No, you pick something.
Inside Info, they have a Reinhardt.
No, you pick first.
No, I don't.
All right, let's aim for 2K.
No, 2K is a little bit too much.
1.5K, guys.
We gotta start lit.
Guys, we gotta...
Whoa.
Mine's low.
Is he?
Apparently I have to deal with Widow too, but that's scary.
I'm gonna go back here.
I don't like being up there.
My positioning is...
It's like positioning as Kiriko is like weird in general.
Oh, I'm so different.
holy thank you all right oh she's still dead he's still dead
he's still dead he's still dead
yeah 1.5 so should i just go monkey or what thank god well
that wasn't called for i'm monkey uh apparently i have to be
the one to deal with widow but it's like it's scary though
Oh, it's very spooky, scary.
Whoa, wait, there's a widow here?
Whoa, whoa.
I'm looking for an old.
Whoa, okay.
He's fine.
Okay, I have to make sure he doesn't die from a widow.
Wait, I think he's fine.
Oh, not him, though.
Oh, shit!
Yeah, that's Kobe.
Look at CC.
Okay, see, I told you guys.
I can do...
Oh, shit.
Any headie I'll take.
I can do Suzu.
I'll take those.
I'll take any headshots.
I'll take any headshots I get.
Wait, I think I can.
Boom!
Let's go.
Let's go!
Oh!
There you go.
He's like Hoppatry.
Of course.
You take what you can get.
Oh my god, we're almost at 1k.
That's a...
It's not a new record, guys.
I've done better.
I've done better, guys.
It's not...
I'm just not very confident in my aim on Kiri.
I just hate projectile projectile I've never actually played
projectile characters at all like I rarely ever play
projectile characters because I just I just hate I hate
projectile so much oh my god you guys okay no you're not no
you're not oh that guy definitely has alt though I was
legit.
I was just like, thank God he doesn't see me.
Does he?
He doesn't... surely he doesn't see me.
Yeah Jesus.
Okay, we saved him, but There is a chance that that Ryan's
gonna shatter now that Ryan's been waiting for a shatter for
Sola God He's been waiting for that shatter Okay.
He's still waiting for that shatter.
He's still waiting for it.
If I do this.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
My bad.
He's coming over.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's won!
He killed two of us!
He was so low!
Oh my god, he almost got him!
Bro, how did our Reaper die?
Oh my god, we're gonna do it.
We're gonna break our...
Cool.
I don't think we have anything.
Yeah, we don't...
We don't have any else.
I don't think we can... Yeah, we can't contest this.
Oh my god, Anna.
Yeah, I need a...
Spot.
Whoa!
I think our... Oh no, yeah, that Winston's dead, dead.
Does not have shit.
Excuse me, how...
How are people dying?
Oh!
That's not good, that... Oh, there we go.
We got a tracer?
Oh my god, why did you...
they why did you say they can walk out they can walk out
guys it's it's not it's not like rivals where the door isn't
there this ends now no
oh what the he got scared it's okay he left he left he left
he left he got scared He left he left he left he left he
left that's good.
That's good that he's good that he's left.
Oh Oh my god, we're at 2k guys see aim low and you'd be
surprised
Why why would you oh my god I wanted I wanted the class
Okay, all right, that's I'll take those
oh my god i have to touch
no no wait that was okay i got i got the headshot though
freaking nice all right here we go cc guys i did hit the
headies oh our other dps is not doing so well though if y
'all have any uh tank recommendations let me know it's a bit
difficult when they're on uh zen honor i couldn't climb i
was trying to go domina all right back to my pastor i
thought i sick but like would the ryan not me no okay all
right cool or do you want to play ram ram is also really
good in the ryan i know i got so i feel like i'll get by the
honors in though i'll find my no you just you just wait for
the you put shield you you form and fight the ride if their
ability is out then we get to walk all right you can do the
same thing on domina watch our flanks they might try
something really oh that's embarrassing i think it's the all
i'm pretty sure it's the i can't even lie bro i'm kind of a
queen one trick so i'm so sorry
to act like it's all right but i think i think we would just
believe you know
jesus christ how do you ask me so much i literally just
looked away for one the game started one second and they
were critical like i don't know nearly one second in
okay all right nice all right maybe should have been fine
that's fine that's fine where is he guys
okay watch this climb boom where's the oh oh my god i'm
bumpus die oh my gosh like i said i I take any, I don't take
any heads I get.
Every time I get a head.
Whoa.
That's pretty cool.
One stink of my life is complete.
Whoa.
Is he okay?
I'm free-heading.
Why take those?
You take a lot of damage.
Oh.
There you go.
That's what we needed.
All right, that tracer should have been tracer the entire
time.
Oh, that guy was so low though.
Oh my god, he's stuck the tracer.
There's no die.
Oh, don't die!
That was the one thing we wanted!
Okay, he's gonna ult.
Okay, I... Junker's gonna ult now.
Are you sure it's still one of them?
Well...
No, I'm back there, sir.
It's okay, I have my ult now, my Suzu again.
Okay, he's gonna Junker Queen up.
I don't have, no longer have Suzu.
I, can you, can you get him here?
Can you do it?
Okay, it's okay, four seconds.
Surely he's not gonna Suzu.
No!
I held it, I held it.
I held it for too long.
What?
Oh, he got solo.
Okay, it's...
Oh, my God.
It's him.
Ramatra versus Farah.
We're coming back, Ram.
Farah's still on the right side.
Can we kill her?
Oh, my God.
I thought I could TP that.
I legitimately thought I could TP that.
That is my bad.
I can't.
It sucks.
I legitimately can't use Suzu.
The moment I use it, the Junker would be like, No Suzu.
No cleanse.
No!
She's still holding it.
Also, there's no way to get top 500 in this God-forsaken
game, because it's literally time to play.
Their new system is not what rank you are, it's just
literally how much you play.
It's play the top 500.
Alright, let's hope she doesn't use it she doesn't know she
doesn't know i i use my cleanse
she doesn't know zen one oh my god also you can you can swap
now i mean if they're not on run you don't have to play that
you can just yeah it's based off of challenger score and to
get challenger score you have the win games.
It's so dumb.
I hate that.
Like, it's literally like how much you play the game.
And I find it really stupid.
Yeah, it's grind to win.
It's just how much you grind the game.
So you can have master players or diamond players.
What the fuck?
Where is he?
Where is he sitting over there?
That queen has been holding off forever because he thinks I
have all.
Or he thinks I have uh She thinks I have the...
I don't want to go for him, but I can't.
Oh, see, he knows.
I mean, it's just me.
Are Lucio...
Are Lucio rolled away?
Are...
Lucio...
Are Lucio rolled away from me?
I was like, don't worry.
The Lucio's got me.
The Lucio, in fact, did not got me.
Do I need to, like, check out something for this far?
I'm dealing with them.
I don't know, is that really the problem?
No, it's not.
I don't even know.
It's a sed, random sed, flanking.
What?
again i didn't kill the zen come on he's so low
i mean sure that's fine oh my god really all right half up
top three could i can go all right that's fine yeah like i
was like please just kill the zen flanking we that's all we
need that's all this is just like me i mean the zen wasted
all because you have to use it and travel 80 miles he had to
travel 80 miles to use that all so like i'm fine with that
it worked out for me because he wasted all you did not have
to use that heart's loose yo
you heard this he was like what
Oh, oh, wait, what?
Oh my god, that's Bob.
Yep.
I mean, you could have died if he died with it.
They wouldn't have enough.
They definitely wouldn't be able to contest it.
Oh, the fair is gonna look then, right?
Most likely.
he's close to juna the worst part is that like there's two
anties yep i knew it i was like there's two anties so like i
have to use it we're down two i knew it i was like the
moment i used i was like the queen has all right you want
you can't hold that yeah 10 seconds remaining.
Are you out that?
No, he didn't.
I hear the Zen.
I don't know if it's the Zen flanking again.
I don't know.
No, he's not.
He's not.
Oh my
god.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
I don't want to peek right now.
I'll be here.
I'll be over here.
Sun low.
One.
That's scary.
Oh, we see nine.
Unlucky.
I didn't even know how our other...
Junker was so... lots of HP!
i did say it could go either way chat i could either get the
gm we do rank all the way to diamond look 4k 4k we're
getting see guys 4k
we still the damage is there the tap the damage is there so
guys we got we got the damage in we got we got the damage in
though slow and steady I yeah I didn't think we were gonna
win our team was not as good as the other team
it's 0-2 at the moment don't worry we can we can salvage
this we can salvage you have to lose some to win some chat
lose some to win some It's part of the trust the process
trust the process everyone Give me death match.
I got warm up.
We warm up Hey, I did my job guys I I did my job.
So I think might need a direct DM C slash whisper All right,
I doxed his battle tag
All right.
There we go.
I forgot that that shows up.
Doki.
Look.
This is how I'm gonna learn.
This is how that Reaper's not doing...
Look, we're both bad.
We're both bad.
This is embarrassing for both of us.
Oh, and the Reaper comes over.
It's embarrassing for both of us.
The Reaper was like, all right, this is my time.
Keep going.
The Reaper comes in with a third party.
I don't think he knows I'm here, right?
Here we go.
I'll take this.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, Battle of the Blood.
Oh, he doesn't know I'm here.
That junk rat is here somewhere.
I heard the tire come all the way here.
Oh, okay.
How did he get there?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I hear like...
There you go.
I take those.
I take that.
Wait, what?
The goddamn third party!
Done playing around.
Alright.
This is at my aim training right now.
My aim training right here.
Ooh, you saw you got me.
I was looking on the floor.
Like, it's so slow.
This projectile.
It's so fucking slow.
I hate it.
Yeah, I got him.
That's...
Who can I fucking...
Oh my god, I got him!
I got him!
Nice.
Wait, there was two vendettas?
It sucks because I don't play Valorant so I don't aim the
head.
I don't know how to aim at the head.
I do body shots.
Where is head level?
Where the fuck is head level.
Oh my god, that's head level.
Oh my god, where?
That's head level.
I figured it out.
Alright, but they are, I feel like they're all like
different heights though, aren't they?
Isn't everybody different heights?
I figured out Reaper's head height.
Come on.
Yes!
Oh shit, not okay.
Oh my god, Who took us to help pack us?
It wasn't me.
Alright, I figured out Reaper's head height.
I figured it was like somewhere here.
Get back to Marvel Rivals, bro.
Maybe that's your game.
Maybe...
Bro, maybe Marvel Rivals your game.
I got him.
They saw the show there.
Looks like somebody's getting shit on.
Bro, go back to magic.
Bro's not.
That's not Starlord, bro.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Oh shit, oh shit, it's oh shit.
It's personal.
It's personal now I saw I saw him I was like fuck I gotta go
Guys, I'm thinking I might have be him too hard.
I think I might have
What?
Is that me?
what was everyone chasing me is not everyone I might have
BM'd a little too hard now oh no oh no I have to be with
other people so I can get defend so I can defend myself oh
no no okay I got the self-heal oh god I gotta get out here I
gotta get out of here I gotta get out of here we gotta be
friends
no I can hear the sword oh thank god I heard the sword I
heard I heard the sword
Brave Sir Doki bravely starts running away.
See, I made it out.
I made it out.
This is it.
This is the game we win, right?
Select your hero.
Choose heroes to ban.
All right.
This is surely.
Surely, right?
All right.
ban diva wait they want on a man oh because he plays high i
mean that makes sense
trying to get oh but then he's just gonna go diva they're
just gonna go diva and then like what the fuck do we do oh
gm4 to gm4 damn i mean the big boy leaves
Oh shit, okay.
380...
That's 381 hours, right?
For this seat?
Holy shit.
I like your mask.
I said I like your mask, dude.
That's 381 hours on...
Merce?
Was that 381 hours?
That's what the...
It stands for, right?
That's a lot.
I thought 200...
No, it's way more.
Oh, it's level.
It's 381 love.
Okay, that's more than hours.
It's 300.
No, top 500 hog.
It's just challenger score.
It's play time.
I'll show you guys what I mean.
That's why I hate about the new system.
It's not how good you are.
It's just how much you play for top 500.
Bro, it is mercy.
I'm pretty sure there's more.
I'm pretty sure the crazy part is that The most.
That's baby shit.
Oh, nice.
They also have hog.
Oh, not nice.
No longer nice.
I don't want to get hooked right here.
Still there.
I think I've got to keep our hog alive there.
I don't want to get hooked, though.
Oh.
Oh, I left our hog one time.
Oh my god.
I left our hog one time.
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, no hook though.
Where the fuck is the Genji?
I want to take off Angles, but I feel like I can because...
I'm going this way.
Oh, um...
Oh, I mean they got points so like does it matter?
I mean they wasted mercy.
Oh shit!
Oh no, that's not good for me.
I mean I have all of them.
level two oh all right okay let's go nope they left oh they
fully left nice i'm gonna go here now i'm gonna take an off
angle here look at me go taking off angles all right look at
me go taking off angles
I feel like we should save our save our DPS over here don't
worry maybe worry a little bit okay that I will say he is a
little stupid oh my god oh I fucking killed my I killed my
cast because he wanted to hook me.
He...
The cast...
The cast wanted to kill me.
I might have...
He killed him.
Oh my god, alright.
I mean, I'll take this, you know?
I don't know if he needs that.
He saved you!
My hero!
And I fucking hear A Masters 2 right now I mean It's alright
It's like alright I don't actually don't even know what is a
good rank in Overwatch anymore Like what Because like
there's no such thing as top 500 I mean there is but it's
just how much you play the game It's not actually top 500 So
like I don't personally know what is considered What rank
would be considered like Top 500 I mean if they come up I'll
let this but they're not pushing up and I don't want to
waste it I don't want to waste like my because they're just
gonna run away and I don't want don't want to let that
happen so they're just gonna run away it's not really yeah
i'll do that
like that cap nice there you go eastport yeah east if you're
in east if you're in the eastport league it's in your top is
grandmaster not good enough it's like it's like all right i
think it's just all right it's like z i think it's like if
you're i think it's grandmaster three i'm pretty sure we
have genji i'll let our mercy heal this stuff but then like
i can't let her heal and like rivals
oh that's unlucky
I like shopping and stuff he's one oh my god oh my god I
think it's GM3 that's when the rank gets good because the
GM3 was when you get into chat lobbies bro die from fall
damage yeah like bro what the
of this they should oh they don't have blades they're not i
don't know not running gangu anymore all right it's time to
play is the mercy jeweled with the cast or the
or the hive my mercy
oh okay he did he's dead he's dead wait if you back we have
we have no fight
Don't get hooked, don't get hooked.
Don't get hooked.
Oh, he didn't get hooked.
He didn't get hooked.
Oh.
I got one shot at.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
Roll Q.
Obviously, roll.
Nobody plays open Q.
I mean, open Q is like...
I don't know if open Q is not...
It's challenging.
just wearing a futaba's uncle oh sir marine vibe at the
moment go okay how are we i don't know okay the other kiriko
they might have 1k more than me more damage than me but oh
that's not good oh that's not good it's okay it's not it's
okay it's okay It's no longer okay.
Oh my god, it's no longer okay.
No, you...
Oh my god, it had all...
Okay, it's fine.
I can TP and then I'll use it here.
It's okay.
See, look at that.
Everything I did in all...
See, I held restraint.
See, guys, it was on purpose.
I held it because I knew my team was gonna win and I didn't
want to double up.
Guys.
Let's try not to double support all because I knew that was
the win condition.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my!
I didn't know about that but that's okay.
That's okay.
We'll just stay here.
Me and the...
hog me and the hog in the corner
so it's friendly that we were saved by the coroner
is that easy look at there look at their dps's uh limbs and
doubts no look look at that look at Sit, sit, and what, and
what?
Sit, sit, sit, sit, what?
I can't say anything.
Not in the big 26, come on.
I can't not hit 20, 26.
Oh, come on.
Bro, that's crazy.
300 plus levels.
It could be the DPS because the DPS is on an alt account.
Fuck, Chica.
Usually, when I hang out with my family, my niece, anytime
she says anything, that's a remotely to those two numbers
she'll like pull my shirt and say look at this look at this
the whole time i guarantee you go to like any elementary
school it's just like is that it's like that in was it was
was that the ton i don't understand the ton whatever but
like and he's gonna be on fortnite like no one owns that
going back in time with memes does someone actually owns the
copyright of the no that wood thing like The Tung Tung
whatever, the Tung Tung Sahar, someone owns the copyright of
that to the point where like someone, like they're putting
it in Fortnite.
Who owns the copyright of it?
That's right.
I was there.
Oh, he's low.
There you go.
You can cop- yeah, you can copyright sloth.
I don't understand.
Like, how is that- like, the fact that that's gonna be in
Fortnite.
Like, Skibity Toilet, I understand, because that was an AI.
But the Tong-Tong was AI.
That's the AI?
Did they, like, made a deal with, like, the AI people?
We don't have Suzu, too.
Oh, that's us.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
That's just...
Ooh.
Good job, team.
I'm getting carried.
It's because you guys left Open Hog.
Sojourn just, like, controls the lobby.
All right.
That's true.
Children is like pro hog.
Yeah, looking at the hog mirror, we're just looking at each
other the whole time.
Oh!
Oh, I thought I would hit that.
Oh, it hit my hog, though.
The one time I hit it, it hits my hog.
You know what I mean.
Oh, my.
Never mind.
I spoke too soon.
Yeah, she got me good with that.
Oh shit, I'm not ulting that.
I'm not ulting that.
I'm not.
It's okay.
They all they did everything.
They used everything.
How many ults is that?
Three?
Yeah.
That's three, right?
Oh, I'm asking.
Let's get back on.
Two for sure.
I don't know.
Acro.
Can you copyright AI means?
Oh my god, that hog's gonna hook me the moment I fucking
show my face.
Bro, you have two fucking pockets, bro.
You should not be dying now.
Hey, here we go.
Okay, here we go.
That's insane, Daryl.
Daryl.
Bye, Hog.
Alright, we got the Hog.
And now they're gonna have a Gengu-ul.
Income Damage.
Nice.
No Gengu-ul for you.
Guys, it's possible.
Guys, where's my Ash?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, he got me.
That's alright.
It doesn't matter.
We got point.
Thank you.
Give me that damage bar!
All right, I shouldn't do that.
Oh, I got much on it.
All right, it's okay.
Kierko, oh, it's no longer okay.
It's okay.
I just...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it's literally hog versus...
But I think our hog is better at hooking.
He's a better hooker.
A better one.
What?
You heard what I said?
Look at him.
He's shirtless.
It's to help with poking.
What?
Why do you think he doesn't wear a shirt?
Oh my god.
You can't afford him.
Look at that.
Where is that?
that Emory going.
Oh, that was a good ass hook too.
A little trippy.
That hook was so good.
Bye.
Oh, okay.
I just jumped.
What?
I missed.
I pressed ship.
I ping.
That must, that's ping.
to be ping my suzu hit my suzu hit and my shift should have
went off
that's bullshit i feel like he's always okay this guy it's
okay i'm gonna take an off angle here there's no off angle
to be hit but like it's the thought that counts
all right bye oh yeah oh my god mercy is so low no he was
right there okay nice all right nice it's the double no oh
my god I did it I did my job
oh my god we did it oh my god i told you guys this was the
game this was the game guys this was this was the game i
told you i gotta kill i got more than just the kill guys i
got 13
i think we had the better soldier i missed i guess i'm
getting better it's a journey guys it's the it's the journey
to improvement look at that easy easiest game of my life I
say as I it was sort of a little bit close but easiest game
of my life you guys don't stop believing chat 1v1 no I'm not
giving him that satisfaction.
I did not watch.
I can just not pick a character.
You know what I can do?
I can eat my chicken while we wait.
That's what I can do.
That's right.
I'll eat my food.
Aquila, do you have super chicken?
Thank you.
There was a lot of hog cranking that match.
I'm going to have a nice meal.
Finish my chicken.
Apparently you can stack until like you can stack in GM.
I thought it was crazy.
I did not realize that.
They made it so that now you can stack now.
Like in the past you couldn't.
But you can stack until you're champ.
Which I feel was like.
I wonder if the games are harder.
Alright.
And Overwatch.
Because, like, M.
And, um, back then, they banned stacking and GM plus.
Um, so you can't even...
You have to solo only.
Because people were abusing it for rank points.
Oh, yeah, I was going to show you as a challenger, swear.
I'll show you guys later.
That's where I finished my chicken.
My cold chicken now.
Better than cold chicken.
with cold pizza yeah i was thinking do you like match up
with other hearts would it be like harder or easier
because in the past i reckon my masters too and he ranked
but but to be fair the games i ranked on was not my fault to
be clear
little chicken sounds okay but it's cold fried chicken
so is it really more depressing
almost done all right i'm gonna wash my hands before i touch
my mouse
i'll be right back
Well, this is five chickens that I've been eating the last
two hours.
I...
Do we have a mercy play on the enemy team?
I'm going to watch my hands.
Welcome to Circuit Royale.
Holy fuck.
What level is that ride?
Oh, I won't be able to tell.
Oh, 98.
Okay, it's not...
Okay, it's 98.
It's not like 321.
that shit is crazy 321
all right oh yeah i finally bought the g the what is it
called a g pro super strike x it's sold i've been in japan i
was like oh maybe i can try and buy in japan basically it's
like the gamer mouse right now like it's sold out around the
world everywhere and the only way um it's like the best
gaming mouse ever because like when you're clicking it like
clicks really really fast um like you know how like when i
click when i do like left click it clicks super fast um it
helps with clicking even faster so like if you think i click
really fast like hold my mouse clicks really fast i can go
faster so so like it got to the point where like people were
getting banned at first in like competitive rank because
people thought like because it was inhumane how fast people
were clicking So people were actually getting banned.
And then now the game realized, like, oh, these are real
people.
So now, so everyone's buying the mouse right now.
And you can't, I was like, I finally ordered it.
I finally was able to order it because it's on back-ordered
right now on the official website.
But like, I was so sad because every time they restocked, I
was in Japan when they were restocking.
So I couldn't, I could have got it earlier.
Inhuman, sorry, inhuman.
It was like inhuman mouse click.
The way, like, it's built.
It was, like, crazy.
So, like, people were, like, actually getting banned in rank
because of it.
Like, the AI detection couldn't...
Thought it was not real.
Like, thought it was, like, AI, I guess.
Or, like, bot...
It was, like, a trigger bot.
It's called...
Like, it's from Logitech, and it's called...
Like, I'm not sponsored.
Like, it's actually...
You cannot get it anywhere right now.
Like, it's sold out everywhere in Japan.
It's, like, really hard to get.
You can get it.
It's back ordered right now, but even as a back order, like,
you won't get it until middle of April.
It's, like, late April.
Imagine your cookie clicker run.
Let me see if I can get him.
Oh, I got him.
This guy.
Get this old man.
get him yeah it's like it's super strike something but i
finally was able to order it like when i got back oh who got
kicked up oh he actually couldn't oh he did you're fine
right you're so healthy oh my god hey guys i might need help
like you're so fat yeah
it's one is is not literally like the best mouse like every
it's like like it's crazy it's actually crazy how how
worldwide you can't get it anywhere you have to order like
oh wait what who killed everybody Oh my god, huge slam.
Oh, fuck, where the fuck did he come from?
Here, I'm gonna get my carry over the me and I'm ulting.
I was not expecting the bomb.
Oh, nobody saw that, Suzu.
I will save my...
Oh, that's not good.
I don't have Suzu right now.
I do now.
Oh, what?
the dive bomb or somebody shoot him quick I think the hard
part about playing Kirko for Ryan is that you have to get
the he can't do as much damage because Ryan is such a damage
sponge what at 504 I was pushing cart guys I was pushing
cart most of the time it's not me I was pushing car guys i
was pushing the car yeah the cat missed and also he like
died right is he okay okay he doesn't does he know him oh is
he okay oh i'm no longer okay i i didn't realize there were
20 people up there Hey Wu Ying, you might need to help heal
the others.
Oh, never mind
No, apparently it's like It's just a huge advantage.
I also got the wooden too.
I haven't unpacked the box yet
Oh Do something I'm right here.
It should be fine Like a shirt Never mind Hey, I'm taking
the gamer advantage if other gamers are using it why would
not be using the same yeah be equal We have to use all the
advantages life give us paid a win
What G logitech mouse is like one of of the best mouse out
there, like the G-Pros.
There we go.
Oh!
Time to try again.
I think I...
I'm using G-Pro Wireless right now.
Custom-painted G-Pro Wireless.
Now I know why Vendetta is bad.
Apparently it's a one-shot.
I understand now.
Alright, just kill him.
I mean, I'll take those.
We got him, though.
We, I mean, we got him.
Oh, goodbye, right.
Hey, free push, though.
Free push.
Oh, wait, it's on me.
Why is it on me?
Why is it?
My ultimate is ready.
My bad.
Y'all just say, why the fuck is that on me?
I'm not near anything.
I don't think my TP Suzu would have saved him when he got
picked up by the cat.
But that's just my honest opinion.
After I saw what he was going through, I Like it seemed a
pretty oh he they actually see nine they actually see nine I
was like They actually see I I don't but the smartest I mean
you just see my visor it was like the perfect zoning visor
is like super sick and cool and way better than that
four-man Sword alt thing Yeah, he looked at them funny and
they walked away.
Yeah
I'm like, I'll take those.
I'll take that C9.
So cool.
Yeah, and six seconds of nobody doing anything.
I just...
You all just looked.
Yeah, wait, someone said...
Was it true that there was, like, AI in the mouse as well so
that it can...
It clicks out where they...
It helps you position your mouse where they think you want
to position your mouse.
crazy if it does I just know it has a very fast clicker it
clicks really really fast yeah predictive clicking is that
true I just know that it clicks really really fast you're
not just looking for an excuse to fight me are you busted I
just know it's I just know like that surely that's cheating
guys I'm all having a great day no because I think it's just
also but makes you feel better oh whoa oh get the out of
here oh no the donut is here yeah i was gonna say that's
crazy if it has predictive flipping but i just know like you
it's you it's just it's so hard to get these those mouse
right now even then i have a backorder on it
You're fine, right?
Am I fine?
Oh shit!
I just took a fucking fist in the face I was like, am I
fine?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
I would like to have a shield, please.
Oh no.
We just need the hard pocket our Rhine because they are
playing the most Friendly conference.
All right.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I'm trying.
I haven't stopped left clicking.
I'm fucking at all.
Oh my god.
He was so far.
Get over here.
Oh, well then.
Hmm, we might have wasted two walls.
Well then, that's...
Hmm.
Look, it was zoning.
We zoned perfectly.
Okay, I want to make sure he is.
Holy heal.
Oh, please don't tell me we wasted another two of us.
Oh wait, we went and we just reeled the staff.
Try not to...
Holy fuck.
Oh my god, the vendetta has all...
The vendetta has all...
That's so scary.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Oh!
We wasted them all!
It's fine.
Everything is okay.
The Vendetta still has all, which is scary, because that...
I did not realize how strong that alt was until now.
Can I get like a little bit of a poke?
Thank you.
He has all the hazards?
I can't respond to that.
How do I respond to that?
It's so fast.
That is so fast.
Holy shit.
I did not expect that.
It happened so fast.
Okay, somebody has to charge it and then the hazard is going
to...
Okay.
It's 5.
It's no longer 5.
It's fine.
It's no longer five.
It's okay.
It's no longer okay.
I was on it!
It happened so fast though.
I'm actually like being miserable here.
You just don't have the kit against that call.
You're just gonna keep getting shot out and you won't live.
Oh no.
Unless!
It's possible!
This is winnable!
This is no longer winnable for me.
Okay, I...
I didn't realize how much damage I was gonna take there.
That was... I will say that was my bad.
That was a my bad moment.
That was my bad.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, that vanilla has out for sure.
Come on, this.
Not me.
Not me, though.
Oh, my God.
Our ride is, like, not having a good time.
Our ride is getting good.
Oh, right!
Right!
Oh, he's one!
He is actually one!
Please for the...
Please!
There's... Oh, at least he's got him.
He might be dead, but he got the tank.
It's okay, we got the tank.
We got the tank.
Isn't Cry the Widow, please?
He's been, he has not, he's still plays this, I mean he's on
tank now, I was gonna be like, damn, he still plays this
game.
Oh my god, I swear to you guys, they do that combo shit.
We're all split up, who you gonna aim for?
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, what is going?
I tried.
I really did.
We have to go in.
Oh no!
Our cats got blind!
Oh no.
We were all split up.
I mean...
What can we do?
There's nothing we can do.
At least we beat their time.
I don't think this rat is going to swap.
Every time I see this gold thing, I...
You know, when you see that, the gold thing, you can sort of
tell that, you know, that it's not swapping time.
If you teach me Tai Chi, I'll teach you Aikido.
Oh, wait, you're not just looking for an excuse to flip me,
are you?
He lives and dies by the Rhyme pick, exactly.
How dare you tell the Rhyme player to swap off Rhyme?
He's hadless on everything else.
Especially Rhyme One Trick.
They're like, they live and die by Rhyme.
Guys, I don't think I'm getting GM, guys.
It's looking less and less likely.
It really is.
Do we have any of the echo?
We do.
I'll hit it.
I'll hit him eventually.
All right, one more fight.
Okay, I'll make sure Wu Yang doesn't die.
We even died.
Oh, this is bad.
This is so bad.
Both our DPS is down, and our Rine is about to...
It's beating.
Oh, this is not good.
Our Rine fed.
Our Rine could have fucking charged back, died.
Whatever.
but what he just did.
All he had to do was live.
Like the bare minimum.
Oh, this is not winnable no more.
This is...
This might not be winnable no more, guys.
Oh.
I don't even know what happened to me.
Oh, this is a lot to push, though.
This is a lot to push.
Ryan doesn't give up.
Never let down.
Never what?
Never back down.
But yet, Ryan always let me down.
He's reliving the war at Eichenville.
He has PTSD.
That's crazy.
He has PTSD from the original war and he still got it.
He's like, put me back in.
Put me back in the Overwatch.
That's what I like to see.
What?
Oh, okay.
I thought he said something else.
PTSD except he lives for it.
He's been in so much.
many words.
He's lost track.
This might be hard.
Which might be a little difficult.
One bad fight in this over.
Well, we have actually no, two bad fights in this over.
It's not PTSD.
It's nostalgia.
Oh.
They have cat.
Anyone, like, they actually have Jetpack cat.
They're giving him artillery.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
They're actually giving him air.
Oh my god, he's so low.
I actually almost killed him, too.
Oh, I should not waste that suzu, whatever.
Might have been a waste for a suzu, but that's fine.
That was bad.
That's no longer a fight.
Guys, I need you to get out of the wall.
Oh my god, please tell me I can.
Alright.
One last fight.
We have to be able to touch the cart.
Dude, we still have to be able to touch the cart.
Are we?
We have to be able to touch the cart.
the cart guys okay we did we did we did we did i mean
they're smart they're actually playing like
they're actually smart they're playing like defense things
that will be good for defense
like for like cart over time oh we should have done that we
should have played over because they have like the cat
Oh my god, I...
I actually clutched that.
Holy fuck.
Okay, not that though.
Oh no.
I thought he was alting me.
I thought he was...
He looked at me at the alt.
He actually looked at me for the alt and turned around.
That's crazy.
No, they're smart.
They're playing everything that counters That, like, is good
for overtime.
That's why I had TPed Because I was like, oh, he's looking
at me.
Oh, yeah.
Fuck.
Okay.
Wait.
I want to show something.
Get out of.
the death match all right okay i'm okay i'll show you guys
where is it leaderboard sorry my count is like hong kong uh
so it's always on so this is challenger score so my
challenger score is i don't i don't even know where my
challenger score is like it doesn't show automatically
apparently which is stupid where's my challenger score is it
here 956 so challenger score is basically you gain and lose
challenger score based off how much you play so you can see
see this champ too this is a guy who's grandmaster one oh
wait five let's do support so 90 000 and he's only champ two
he's chronically online and has played already I don't even
know how many hours but that's a he's already played this
much hours of Overwatch um that that's a lot like a lot of
hours he's played like this much hours like 50 like I don't
know 100 hours of of Overwatch in general So, all the way
here, you can see GM players.
You can see, like, Master 4, because 5,000 challenge your
score.
And then you...
Oh, wait.
And then, let's see, all the way back here, 5,816.
That's...
Oh, sorry.
There's...
Like, a lot of them...
A lot of them are hiding their profile, so it's very hard to
tell.
But, all right, we'll find someone that isn't hiding their
profile.
And then...
Masters 2.
All right, there we go.
He has played 58 hours of Sumetra.
Master, top 470 right now, 6,000 challenges score.
Because they have already played 58 plus hours of Kierkega.
They have a 52% win rate, by the way.
52% win rate.
And they're currently top 500.
They're currently here.
Masters 2, top 500.
A GM2 player is low.
were ranked than the Master 2 player, because they don't
play as much.
Let's see if we can see them.
They play
half of their hours.
Sorry, Kirko.
Sorry.
You know, they all look, they all like blur together, you
know.
But like, half the hours of the Kirko above them.
Higher rank, though.
Higher rank.
Whoa, Toki.
Kierko.
Look at that.
So, you can't say that.
So, I was thinking about that.
You know, like, the host Anron thing where they were
showing, like, Anron, Juno hair, Juno hair, Kiriko hair.
So, look, 21 hours.
This is the person below this guy.
Where is he?
is dumb i this guy this oh wait this is this guy oh my god
the guy this guy's champ four and he's lower rank than the
guy who's master's five so it's literally time to play yeah
the on round with the torp hero is perfect it's literally
just how many hours do you spend on um on overwatch type
deal so top 500 doesn't mean anything now because it's
literally whoever plays the most can you can literally hit
top 500 as a diamond player figuratively if you just keep
spamming um but like if you look at here okay rank wise
masters five you can be top 500 as masters five there's no
rank minimum it's just challenger score you gain and you
gain and lose score based in rank uh the higher rank you are
you gain more challenger score yeah top 500 is just play to
win.
If you play enough in the Masters, you will get top 500.
Yeah, it's just grind.
Grind to be on the leaderboard.
So it's not actually your rank.
I saw Diamond play in top 500 before.
I don't know.
Maybe back when it was the day, like the first week.
The first week on the leaderboards, I saw it's just
playtime.
That's why getting top 500 doesn't mean as much i think
getting gm means more than getting top 500 because the fact
that i'm masters two and like top 500 is technically masters
five oh did it change it i mean thank god because it was so
sad seeing a diamond player in top 500 it was so i was like
that's sad that's really sad yeah it's literally just you
just play if you're masters are you playing enough you can
actually make it
see number rank 499 i don't know maybe i can you know let's
go lucio my first my first main lucio was my first main
there's always science to be done
Mizuki's not that good in ring.
He's like...
He's very situational.
Depends on the comp.
Oh my god, we have Mora?
Okay.
Don't have a Kierko.
Might not be idea, but we'll try.
He was a skater, boy.
She said, see ya later, boy.
He wasn't good enough for her.
Okay, also I should not have used it.
Cool.
I'll stay here for now I wasted my app I should have used it
when we're in the gates are now I can use it let's add to
here oh my god okay all right I did not expect a punch to
the fucking truck he was aiming for that too I hate playing
Lucy against Doomfist by the way I'm so bad playing in
Doomfist on Lucy I'm actually, I'm fucking, I'm swapping the
Kiri.
I'm actually, I was really, really bad against Doomfist on
Lucia.
There is a montage of me dying to Doomfist non-stop as
From like a, what was it, from Zebra?
Was it Zebra?
I don't remember.
From like a Doom 1 trick.
Made a fucking montage of me dying to him non-stop.
It was not great.
It was not ideal.
I don't want it.
I'm just gonna TP.
I did not fuck with that.
I will say.
Okay, I tried.
Alright.
I hit him once, so he does.
Okay, okay, I just, I felt like I couldn't dodge that.
As long as it's not me.
that's unlucky oh
goodbye I guess goodbye me it's a zebra I remember and it I
just I don't know I feel like his his punch literally just
like it's like magnetic to me I'm just a magnet to doom
punches and I just don't know how to to deal with it.
Who's he going for?
Ah.
Oh my god.
I mean, I'll go here.
I don't want to be the one counter swapping one.
I don't need to.
We need to deal with this impasse.
All right.
I had a look.
Wait, our Wu Yang does that.
Okay, I think it's okay.
Are we being swapped after me?
Woo!
Alright.
If we want, I'm ready to go.
I think our Winston has, oh, right?
Please tell me I have.
There we go.
Oh, shit.
the doom there we go not just any doom we just need vendetta
guys from the overwatch cut scenes vendetta always wins
against doofus that's
all we need nice if she can win against them in the
animation then we can win against them here oh wait they
badminton they knew
Oh my god, maybe he won't punch me Yeah
Okay, I've done my best I pocketed you enough I pocketed
I'll just say If you died, I've like No one on earth can
save you
If he's If you're if you still died with this pocket like
that's on you at this point like even god can't save you
whoa i'll make sure he's alive
wait how did oh oh
okay i'm i tried i tried about soon though I mean where is
he I like jumped on top of him where did he go
shit all right he's fucking unless oh I could do this oh I
leave now one I was like, oh, oh, oh, goodbye.
This is where I say goodbye.
Holy fuck, I actually, I, that was so...
Nice.
Okay, we can't die because he has no luck.
Okay, you can technically kill him.
There we go, I was gonna say.
headshot.
Alright, I know where his head is now.
I know where Doomfist head is positioned.
I have not played Dribbles since White Fox came out.
Since I came back from vacation.
I heard, like, triple support.
I'm just tired of triple support.
That's really it.
But I feel like there's nothing they can do about it unless
they introduce Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Unless they introduce Role Q, I don't think they can do
anything about triple support.
But I'm just really tired of triple support and I heard that
with triple oh oh that's unlucky got knocked off I heard
with like um with the three bans all supports are bad but
then people are still playing triple support people are
still playing support they would ban six supports and people
will somehow it'll just be like the shittiest supports
imaginable but it's still triple support that's the thing
there'll still be triple support oh that's unlucky oh
wait he oh my god they still live I was gonna be like wait
they live oh he's not gonna Oh,
I was so close.
I was so close to getting up.
Yeah, I haven't played my rivals.
I was just really tired of triple support.
It's just, I personally think it's like super boring.
It's just too many supports, you know?
What can people do?
I mean, the only thing you can really do is enforce 2-2-2.
Because even if you try to nerf supports, you're forcing
triple support.
You're forcing triple support because there's not enough
heals.
So you have to play triple support.
I mean, I stopped playing Overwatch because of goats.
I was so tired of goats.
It's the same thing.
And then I went to it was just so boring.
yeah yeah and then it's like it's really frustrating because
it's like team please play goats or i can't or we can't win
and you have to beg your team and rank to play goats because
then you won't win so it was just so tired because it's the
same in rivals you have to beg your team to play your triple
support or you can't win like but like in overwatch you
don't have to beg anybody to play a specific role type deal
or like play like a specific cop you can play whatever the
fuck you want.
Goat was triple tank, triple support.
And then if somebody had...
If the enemy team was running Goat, you have to run Goat, or
you don't win.
Oh my god, the double dings, though?
Yeah.
That's like the...
That's like... That's what's the most frustrating part.
Like, you have to play it, or else like, there's no point.
Like, why... Why won't you play it?
You know?
And then...
is it's like the same way um it was the same in rivals you
have to play triple support or you lose the game triple
support in lower elo yes but in high elo it's the only way
to win like high elo it's all it's like if you don't play it
it's just there's no point
what oh my god i thought our brig had heals but i guess not
have healers, guys.
Oh, this is not good.
Because I have every instance, it was just like, we had to
play triple support.
Because it's like, people are saying, like, oh, this
character has a low win rate in some, one, in an Elo, in,
like, all Elo's, but, like, it depends on, like, what Elo it
is.
We get Nana.
Objective lost.
Oh my god.
Oh shit, I don't have to press shit.
In my instance, every time I played in high E though, and it
was triple support versus triple support.
If it's triple support versus non-triple support, shit, I
don't have anything.
It was just not fun.
Not fun at all.
So it's really that GAM...
Oh my god, the GAM would triple support or like gambit
low-key too it was just not fun
i just hate how like people have to beg to like please play
triple support please or please play ghost please where
was he what i clearly what can i do
the gambit never falls i have well i don't know if it's if
we can
back in here i don't want to i'm waiting for my for them to
come out all right here we go oh we couldn't touch i'm
swapping i feel like fuck it i will not i'll run on her
behind
we need an honor i'll run on her watch me get on her i
haven't played on in a while
Right here.
This is it.
Oh, never mind.
That should have been a hit.
I don't have sleep.
I knew it.
I knew that was gonna happen.
I was like, I have nades.
That's it.
That's all I can give you.
I can only give a nade.
Oh, please peek me.
Oh my god, break please.
Holy shit.
Oh, Emery, please.
There you go.
I'm so scared.
That car was so hungry for heals.
I...
That car was so hungry for heals guys.
I have no like perks though.
I mean three minutes of this?
I don't know guys.
I definitely should have swapped the Winston a while ago.
For sure.
I hope I'm nice.
If I can see him.
I don't want to get too close up there.
One last fight and that's it.
I can't see with this yellow glowing thing.
Oh no.
I winced in through.
Oh my god.
I wasted nays too.
I can't.
Oh please.
Oh, please!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
That brick saved my ass!
That felt like hell.
Yeah, I think it'll be fine.
We have to do something there.
Let's hope our Winston doesn't die.
Oh, no, who will protect me now?
Nobody will protect me.
Nobody!
I was like, no one will save me now.
Unlucky.
I was just like, the moment.
moment my break is dead I knew it was over it was over the
instant jump hey but London Spitfire though one of my
favorite I my mouse is literally London Spitfire colored I
did I won two games it's like two three I think it's two
three a record right now
like four days the entire grind i've just been playing kiri
kiri lucio and brig yeah it's two three right now wait i
could go even i can go even all right death match
yeah sometimes you get those two three maybe i can get back
masters one what
Oh, there is shit.
I haven't seen...
Whoa.
Come on.
Why he run away from me?
Oh, now he wants to fight.
Oh my god, now you want to fight.
After your full HP, you fucking nerd.
I don't have time to be weak.
Maybe that's why I'm losing.
Someone was clearly not picking up their slack.
So...
you like that flick she got shot on and deathmatch you like
that flick someone maybe maybe it's not me maybe it's
someone else on a dps role
see now i know it's definitely not me
no hold on
It's just that easy.
You think so?
Can't be me.
Oh, Kiri's bad.
The fuck do I play now?
Maybe I should play Lari.
How did that?
No, I'm inspired after that.
After that, I think I'm inspired.
Alright, I guess not.
Alright, we should...
up to 18.
I don't know what to play.
I think it's about the right time for a W.
That's what I'm thinking.
I guess Juno?
What the fuck do I play with this guy, Bab?
What?
I mean, what's better, Tom?
Let's win.
I don't know what goes in line.
Bad theory.
What are you watching in the background?
I guess either Bab or Juno?
I don't know.
I'm really bad at that.
That's my text out now.
Oh, I can add up?
Let's go.
That's actually juice.
I love that.
Oh mercy.
You know what I deserve.
I have that for my my my siblings and then I have the like
puzzle solved one for my girlfriend.
I deserve to play mercy after today after the last couple of
games.
It's not that hard if you like download I get my plus one
mercy after a couple of games.
No you can do it on Apple.
Okay thank god.
I'll explain to it after we're done fighting.
It's a bit in the process.
Not that hard but I'm also confused right now.
cannot do two things at once.
Fuck you knew it.
I was like, I heard.
I hear him.
Oh, big, big, big.
Like, he's still over.
Hello.
Please help me.
Please help.
There we go.
Yeah, I was gonna say, it's good I didn't explain anything
during that fight, or else I would have very much not done
what I did.
I was like, please help.
If you go on your, like, laptop, and you download, like,
sound you want off YouTube, you can then plug your Apple
iPhone into your laptop and upload this song to your iPhone
and then open it in iTunes and it'll be selectable as a text
sound option.
That's cool.
What the fuck?
It's a trick I learned from my mom.
I don't even know what he's talked with.
What this man is...
Oh my god.
What is this man even?
Talk?
We know.
We want...
Oh
My god, I feel like everyone is low and then nobody is
looking at me I don't even know I just saw like three people
low, but they are all out of LOS I was like, please look at
me, please if you're low Just look at me It's a pro tip I'm
not queen, I'm not queen, I'm not queen, I'm not.
He's still killing her, he's still killing her!
Okay.
We gotta just live, just, just relax, just wait a second.
Yes, just please, wait a second.
Hold on, um...
Just walk away, walk away, everyone walk away.
We can still kill it.
You wanna fuck this, I might be dead.
You ready?
Not me though.
I just got so lulled.
There's an onro behind him.
Not me though.
I get fucked, I guess.
I didn't get so lulled.
Why?
You got the aura, I don't know.
He senses your time.
Brick, brick, tronning, brick tronning.
I'm going as fast as I can.
Oh, yeah, I'm tronning.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh.
This is the craziest fucking maneuver on the brig.
Oh, why are we throwing?
I mean, I got the brig for you, so...
What do you mean, I got the brig?
they use rally the previous fight they're probably kind of
close to queen if I gotta be honest okay I don't know why we
can go hard with my old go on they might try and like high
noon I wonder if the iron is behind us again oh I wonder I
wonder if the Aron is behind us again.
They did not put up a lot of resistance.
I wonder if the Aron is behind us.
I'm gonna pop my ult really early.
I wonder if the Aron's behind.
She's gonna try and kill me.
I wonder if the Aron's behind us.
Hmm.
I wonder if she's still behind us.
Castle one.
Go in there.
I wonder if the I runs behind us.
I wonder.
I don't think so.
I just got a DM from Mega Mulani saying, please can you say
Super Gomez?
Did you go by Super Bondes in the past?
Please.
I wonder.
spin the wind like what dude whenever i get nah she can't be
right jeez i think that's my vibe that's funny bro it's
someone's behind us guys couldn't be the honor on right i
wonder if she's behind me i want the message on angry face
truly not you can trust me but you also have to trust that
i'm gonna do the like i'm gonna attempt to do the i'm just
imagining things just the voices in my head again that's
some that's just how it goes sometimes stop behind you she's
in front of you are you like streaming right now is that how
he's hearing me no not me oh wait how the fuck is he how is
he talking to me in dms he's a stalker actually wait you can
find me what the fuck there is someone streaming in the
lobby right now there has to be let no who could it be i'm
not one on point i'm on there queen i think jelana but their
name shall not be exposed because I'm alone.
I wonder if the on-runs behind me.
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead this time.
No, he's dead this time.
Is it I who's streaming?
Is it me the whole time?
Is it you?
The whole time?
Oh my god, who could it be?
I don't know.
I'm on spring break.
I have nothing else to do.
Oh, they don't even now.
I'm cringing.
Guys, they're playing the unfun character.
Yeah, that character's got us.
I'm taking an app.
Oh, wait, throwing Bastion.
There you go.
Luckily.
Okay, there you go.
Grab this.
If only Onrun was behind me.
No!
He swapped off Onrun!
He swapped off!
No!
Who will be behind me now?
Who will be behind me now if not the odd run?
I don't know what to do Yeah, I got yeah, I get triple hatch
on him No, I don't know what to do when the odd one's not
behind me
There you go.
I want kill participation.
Let me come over here.
Let me get this kill There you go Good ass.
I'm gaming.
Watch the flick now.
There we go.
I'm gaming.
See, I used to be an anime.
All those years ago.
Like I said, I used to though.
Holy shit, where the fuck's...
Oh shit!
Oh shit, my hubris!
My...
Oh, you're full.
Never get cocky, guys.
Never get cocky.
Kaki.
Oh my god.
Guys, never, never get cocky.
My lorry just didn't heal me.
Karma will always get you.
Because I did not know the rest of them was there and I was
trying to kill behind them.
Karma will always get you.
I'm still down one of you.
I'm just, you know.
I'm walking this vest again.
I was just surprised my knee didn't go off there.
Oh, that's really bad.
It's just fine.
I don't want anyone.
Oh, come on.
We went for that to the last second.
Uh, three, three, three, three, three.
Where is everyone?
Okay, I sort of threw that.
Oh, shit.
He was sleeping.
Okay, I literally threw that because I didn't know where
everyone was going.
I...
Okay.
I threw that.
I didn't know where everyone was.
I literally ran away from everybody.
I was like, I'll take the flank.
I'm gonna take the off and go.
And I was like, wait, where's everybody going?
Yeah, they were everywhere, but where were you?
I don't even know.
I was also everywhere.
All right, I'll go.
What the fuck?
But you guys, I don't know where you guys are going, and I'm
concerned.
90, 90, 90.
He knows.
Okay, just win now, win now.
That shit's super fun.
Oh, blow him up.
Fuck that bash.
Hey, God.
Dvd, Dvd, Dvd.
Oh, no, now they have that.
Oh, you have to be.
Oh, Dv1, Dv1, D1, D1, D1, D1, D1, D1, we need point, we need
point, we need point.
We need point!
Cast one, cast one, cast, cast, we'll be one right side.
You have no need help.
We're going.
We're going to attack.
Everybody is what?
Break, break, break, break.
He's one.
Okay.
Wait, I can't touch.
I got it.
Oh my god.
We need to go for end on top right.
We need to go top right.
I can't.
How is this cast is not dying?
What is he fucking made of?
Guys, I wish I had run was still behind us.
I get him with one HP, and then someone's on him instantly,
and then I get on the kill cannon, so now he's full HP.
One, two, one.
Guys, I missed the thing on Ron chat.
I really do.
He came alive the second I got on that map.
Okay, okay, I'll focus up the Samoan.
Where did you go?
Ben Tracer.
I know, Tracer's still up.
Never mind.
Oh no, at the end there, I totally missed three shots.
Before that I had gotten him low.
All right, let's see.
I totally whiffed.
That's definitely true.
I will not, but that wasn't every time.
all right here you go I wish two of my shots are used at one
HP those are the most embarrassing all right okay we're
focused up focus up no more we're fucking around now that's
the positivity that I need to hear we're gonna right side
with you yeah I'll do it too okay never mind it didn't work
I broke a I'm gonna dash stuff right here.
The last thing waited, the last thing was a turret.
Yeah, you can go.
I mean, I got the anti on him.
Any help?
I need help, any help.
Help me help me.
Oh, we don't have cleanse though.
We just need care.
I got fine.
Oh, I need care.
I need care.
I'm still dead.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Oh, fuck.
We got D.
We got D there.
Oh, shit.
Help me, help me.
He had sleep, so.
I've got just one HP.
Nice.
You got blessings?
All right, there you go.
I'm focused up.
You can tell I'm focused up.
I'm not talking.
I'm trying to position myself.
Oh my God, we got my crack hole here, that big.
You might need to push in some here, like right now.
Yeah, I'm walking, I'm walking.
Come on, we're walking.
We're good, we're good.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, my need hit too.
Show me, show, show.
Oh, shit.
Help me, please.
Hello.
I can, I can, I can all, if you guys back point.
I'll look for the, uh, fish, fish, fish.
Yeah, just live, just live, just live.
I'll push the push.
All right.
It's here.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I need, where did the Ana team from?
Oh my God.
Why don't you be?
I'm actually helping this.
Oh my God.
They're on point.
Get on.
No.
We couldn't get on point.
I don't think I can do much of it.
against that I was seeing it like a drop on her head I'm sad
we don't have nano yeah but they use their nano they're okay
you should have built his nano faster that's not on me it's
coming after me maybe Anna I yeah got you got you got you
got you oh fuck I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay oh we
got we I can go like super hard with my ult.
Alright, I'm ready, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I'm in for you.
No, I bet it, I bet it.
Whoa.
Okay, she can she, pick me, pick.
We're very slow right now though.
How about already?
Okay.
I can't.
Oh my god.
Guys, this might not be winnable, guys.
Can we like go top right first instead of going right first?
It's very difficult to set the dive.
I still have some fighting.
Alright.
Guys, I'm...
I don't know, guys.
I'm not very hopeful anymore.
I miss...
I really miss...
Why did they stop throwing?
Why?
Guys, I don't understand.
Why did they stop throwing?
The best one's making the best.
Just wait for them.
I can go left.
There we go.
Break your break, break your break.
I thought that was it.
Oh my.
Well, I think I'm fucking dead.
No!
We are killed.
Oh my god.
Guys, I know it wasn't me.
I know it wasn't me, guys.
Guys, it wasn't me.
It doesn't matter.
Even I hit the ult.
It wouldn't have mattered.
I'm trying to find a tick.
Guys, it's okay.
This is where...
This is where it turns around.
This is...
I don't know.
If I nano that Bastion, maybe he could...
have lived but i think my other two teammates would have
still died i think our brig i don't think like even if i
nano the bastion our brig and diva was gonna die regardless
they were not they were not gonna live i don't think yeah i
think i'm pretty sure they got a new chart like i would have
saved the bastion but we would still be like down to over
other It was just unfortunate that they were all grouped up
during that bastion note.
Alright, he's trying to find a tank account.
Let's see.
Sorry, I was just looking at where.
Sorry.
Hang on work messages.
Let me look through work messages real quick.
Alright, let's see.
Sorry, I got my thumbnail.
uh oh i assume that better be him that'd be awkward i
randomly i i hope that's all right i hope that's all right
that is okay i was gonna say i hope i didn't randomly add
someone
select your hero
select heroes to ban
all right here you go tank down be fair we've been getting
some pretty mid tanks though i think tanks is like one of
the hardest roles to learn because you're it's just you you
know you don't have another dps or support to rely on but
like on tank like if you're a bad tank you're it just
stovet.
You can just get tanked if by the other tank and you can't
do anything about it.
I'll find my own path.
Anyone requires my assistance.
Please inform me.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go!
Don't worry, I'll be different now.
This is where it turns around guys we're playing main roles
now no longer off rolling well i was playing main role this
is this is it guys this is this is where things change right
here look see um i'm i'm picking off angles guys look at me
go Look at that!
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
I might have should have helped you.
Maybe.
I could have helped you earlier.
That was my bad.
Definitely could have helped you earlier.
I thought he had more to live for.
It's okay.
I'm pocketing.
Oh, goodbye.
That's not on me.
That was not on me.
I don't have suzu now though.
Okay.
Oh, it's so healthy.
We're so healthy.
We are still so healthy.
Look at that.
There have been any healthier.
I haven't seen so much health in my life Oh my god And I
have Okay, I don't even need to use up Okay, that's just my
Juno It's fine We're already gonna land here I mean, we got
the point Alright I'm gonna go to the point now What is she
gonna do?
Shoot me?
She didn't shoot me Ha ha ha ha I'm sorry I could have saved
this guy 20 times
All right Punch someone else and you might get a point I
know this guy's dad is doom only Position betting damn damn
You know what let me go Oh, I got, I got, oh, I, that may,
that may actually was so smart that.
That took away my entire title.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh, oh, it's no longer fine.
See?
Oh.
Everything is okay.
See?
See, even though...
Oh my god.
Look at that, everything is okay.
Well, not for her, but for me, yes.
Like, I'm so much better at this tank roll than DPS.
Oh my lord.
Okay, the may as well...
Maybe I should have stood still.
Okay, this is my off angle.
Look, see it?
Look at that.
Boom!
Oh wait, that's spot.
Where's the point?
The point is here.
Okay, goodbye.
Alright.
Yeah, it's Kirko as 2B.
Bye, everybody.
Don't worry.
Toby.
Yeah, I got it.
They just want more kills.
I hear people to my left.
Oh, it's a Reaper.
What is he gonna do?
Our Juno is just gonna fly away.
Like what can he do?
Oh, okay.
This time he's fine.
I don't know about our Domina, though.
I'm still fine.
Hello.
Oh, shit.
Guys, I need help.
Wait, I still have it.
I still have it, though.
I still have it.
Not anymore.
Not.
I did.
Okay, look, I did contest that for so long.
I got- I contested for so long, though.
Oh, I- Ooh, that might not be the smartest thing to do.
I did my part, exactly.
I did my part.
Oh, what the fuck?
What is he doing here?
Alright.
Hey.
Um, they used a lot of ults.
All right, that's awkward.
I had- I mean, I was gonna die regardless, so I died on my
own terms, you know?
All right, let's see It's here You know, I died on my own
terms guys Two fights and it's over Jesus we defended that
for so long, too
All right, it's all right.
It just gave them a little freebie.
I hear the Reaper here.
I want to be careful.
Yeah, there he is.
I knew it.
I was like, I heard the Reaper.
I'm trying as a soldier.
Heal right now.
I'm trying to defend you guys.
Oh my god, I still live.
There you go.
Oh my god, we actually did it.
Holy shit, oh my god.
Positioning!
And that's how you position.
Let's go!
Positioning!
Oh my god, he swapped the weeing.
I don't think...
Bro, I don't think it's...
It's the fact... I don't think...
I don't even remember what he was.
That's how... Oh, wait, he was Juno.
I don't know if Wu Yang did, though.
I guess Wu Yang is more aggressive.
I think Lucio would be better.
Usually you just go with Lucio Akira, so I'm like,
surprised.
That'll be fine.
I don't have to use anything.
I'll let my Wu Yang build up.
I was invisible somehow, I know.
much i believe the thing is it's hard to let yourself build
all for this game versus rivals because like your heels
don't do that much in general i feel personally wait he's
going to point
oh i know where your head height is oh
Yay!
See?
It got easier.
It actually got easier.
Look at that.
Three... Oh my god, I almost deranged.
Three...
Look at that, guys.
Three, four.
Getting back there.
It's three, four now.
why aren't you playing dps because i don't know how i don't
just know how to play three characters on dps soldier emery
and cat tracer i mean cast yeah actually four so anything
that goes pew pew i can only play these four characters but
even then it's not great when you're playing in master
master supports it's not the best it doesn't it doesn't feel
so good now arriving at the shambha because it's like i'm
not used to low healing i don't know where the health packs
are too so like you know it's sort of the double whammy i
don't know where health packs are and the heals are so bad
in terms of like um if you position yourself like wrong at
like just a just once you're fucking dead i'll find my own
path so that i don't like playing dps in overwatch it was
right after it's a lot harder because you it's like i
couldn't look her in the eye for weeks those are so low now
i am glad you've resolved your differences i played dps more
so when dps felt like they're invincible Yeah, I think I got
the Grandmaster on Soldier only.
In Overwatch 1, not in Overwatch 2.
In Overwatch 1, I got to GM with Soldier only, because it
was so easy.
I just fucking, I was liggs.
I was just running around.
I just ran everywhere.
It's not hard to do.
Oh, I have Juncker.
And they have Hansa there.
I want to take off Angles, but I'm too scared.
Send me here.
Oh!
Go, Lucio!
Go!
That's right!
Oh my god, don't let me get logged.
Don't let me get logged.
luck yeah it's literally a point-and-click adventure when i
was playing soldier
oh my god go go go thank you stop going gangu got scared he
stopped going
why are you so scared
that was that might have been a bit too risky that's just
just maybe just maybe oh shit
Yeah, we should kill her.
Oh, it's alright, we're fine.
Everything is fine.
We won the fight.
Look at that.
I looked at them one time and I was like, nope.
I was like, nope, I'm done.
Okay, Lucia, you can go in.
You go do your thing, I'll push cart.
Yeah, you go so...
Oh.
cool if it worked if it worked it would have been so cool
that's all i'm gonna say if it worked if it uh if it worked
it would have been so cool it just didn't work it just
unfortunately didn't work
but it could have been yeah I Would have been a hero
Okay, ready that'd mean that's fine That was a little too
late I mean sure Like you just That's fine There you go I
didn't think we needed though.
I think...
I don't know.
Maybe we did need the beat, but yeah.
I think my...
I think my Dom...
D'Omina.
I keep saying Domina because it feels like her name should
be Domina.
But, like, it's not.
It's not.
It's Domina.
I mean, sorry.
It feels like it should be Domina, but it's Domina.
Leaf, welcome to the D'Omina farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I don't know.
For some reason, I feel like her name is supposed to be...
to be Domina, but it's Domina.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, I meant...
Oh my god, I keep getting confused.
Sorry, her name is Domina.
I keep thinking it's Domina because I...
It just felt like it was Domina.
I keep...
Yeah, it's like...
I keep pronouncing it wrong.
I keep thinking it's not that.
I keep getting confused, like, right now.
But it is Domina.
It's not Domina
It is Domina not Domina.
Oh, what?
Why?
Don't be funny if I got shot here.
Oh, he got shot there Did I hit it?
Oh, I hit it I hit that too Oh,
never mind.
Wait, where's my cart?
I wasn't pushing it!
I wasn't pushing it the entire time!
I was like, where's the cart?
I got too into it.
Oh, that's bad.
Oh, that's also bad.
Oh.
I'd...
If I had been pushing that card a little earlier, I'd...
Oh, that's awkward.
This is your...
It's not...
I shouldn't...
It shouldn't just be me.
Guys.
It's the Lucille's fault for dying first.
Chat.
Okay, Winston definitely has alt now.
Oh, shit.
Jesus Christ, I'm fine, though.
I don't need to use Suzu yet.
Oh, what?
How did our Lucio die?
To be fair, junk is like a hard Lucio counter, though.
I don't think it matters if I live or die here.
We're all trying to find who forgot to push the card.
Mr. FluffyKids, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, Lucille died first.
So is it really my fault that I didn't push the card in
time?
That forgot to push the card in time?
Hmm.
Is it really my fault?
Oh my god, he was so...
What the fuck this Winston keeps forgetting to look?
Oh.
Guys, guys, I was healing my team, so is it really my fault
that we didn't push the cart again?
Look, look guys, we got the cart.
Look at that, see, look, we got the cart.
It's not my fault.
We still got the cart.
It's not easy.
Look at that.
See, guys?
It works.
I'll find my own path.
Look at that.
For how much that Lucer's DPSing?
His damage is not as high as I thought it'd be.
Not gonna lie.
I swear.
Winner, winner.
Chicken dinner.
You have, I don't like, I mean, I think that's the one thing
I like about Rivals is that when you touch the cart it'll
move for you.
You don't have to have one person on the cart at all times.
You flip it, yes, but like, that's what I like.
That does it.
Five, four.
It just feels nice to just be able to have someone pushing
it.
Oh my god.
I...
Thank god he can't aim.
Thank god.
That could have been very bad.
She still...
Oh, he got...
He swapped off widow.
What?
I...
Okay, that was weird.
Because I try to...
I hear a junk rat hear me.
Okay.
Alright, here you go.
Yeah, that was a little too close for comfort.
Give me a little haircut.
Cool.
Oh, nice, you got it.
It's fine.
I'm like right here.
Oh, shit!
Oh, sh- Oh, stop!
I clapped my hands!
I clapped my hands were clapped!
My hands were clapped!
I clapped!
I clapped it!
What happened to my TP?
Enemy here!
My fingers moved!
Hand clapped!
I don't understand!
Hands clapped!
Oh my god!
Alright!
My gift to you!
Where's my diva?
There it is.
I think it's easier to clap as Luna than Kiri.
There's like that two second delay.
Not even.
Thank God his tracking is worse than my projectiles.
Remember, where is he going though?
I mean, not good.
I think I might be dead.
It's my hell, Mary.
That's okay, we have feet.
That's okay.
Nice.
He broke it down.
Oh, no, not nice.
Where is our Lucia?
Where did our Lucia go?
You're so far away from the soldier.
How dare you on that other side of the map?
Wait a minute.
How did you get there?
Why is my team on the left?
my other healer on the right like what happened oh he's so
scared oh
my god i'm trying my best oh i'm getting out of here i don't
know where that card is coming
we live we fucking live the lucio to the left and the the
the curia on the right
I've got you.
It somehow worked.
He was so confused.
That was, it's like, who do you shoot?
Pick one.
The double of the supports supporting each other.
They're like, who do I shoot?
There's two very juicy supports.
Just sitting there.
Look at that.
Alright.
3.
Now it's three four look
at that see I told you I told you we can turn it back give
me death match oh wait this is not him oh never mind I do
associate for like one second there
you go that's what overwatch does to someone and i came back
from vacation i was like it's overwatch time it's it's
i was like yeah let's go it's overwatch time
all right i'm ready
traveling to nepal i'm ready All right, what do I play?
Oh my god, wait, how many hours?
Oh 150.
Okay, it's not as bad.
She's 150.
It's not all my own.
I bet you it's These two
Bet you It's these two But I'm getting better.
I'm getting better at aiming with here go I It's
improvement.
We're getting there.
Man, there you saw like a purple Cassidy.
Oh my god, I hit her.
It's like, I hit her one time.
Oh my god, guys.
I'm so good.
I hit her, guys.
I hit one shot.
Holy fuck.
That's insane.
look it's oh my god I hit again I got another shot in wait
did we all I make it look at that now 300 let's go I'm doing
it don't worry Cass you and me you don't need that mercy
pocket you got something better well not really a suzu A
cat, a Kiriko that hit one shot.
Oh my god, please, please, please, please, someone clap!
Someone clap!
Don't want to clap!
Why did everyone leave me?
Okay, maybe it wasn't better.
Look, that's not my fault.
He died so fast.
I try.
I look me and you.
Oh shit.
Okay, you and me.
I'll do this again.
Look, look, look, look.
I told you.
And now I leave.
Look at that.
See, I told you this is better.
This is better than a mercy pot.
Lock it.
Like, look at that.
I told you it's better.
We could do this again, Cass.
You and me.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
All right.
That's not on me, though.
I don't know if I want to do a round two of this.
but oh oh we need to uh no it's worth it
i'm gaming right i told you i'm getting better look at that
saved we used both support outs but but saved you and me
cassidy okay maybe i should have healed him maybe i should
have feeling that that that was my bad i thought he was five
without me i was just trying to take it off angle i
just wanted to take it off oh my god oh my god i'm gaming oh
my god we're dead we are so i was gaming though i was gaming
look at that 830 damage but more damage than the other curie
just remember that more damage than the other curie came to
arms of the angel but more damage than the other curie now
that you aren't feeding her scraps oh yeah when you get
grabbed you're supposed to look away because so you don't
get headshot Which is smart if you think about it.
That's right, more...
In terms of me versus the other Kiri...
I have more damage than them.
Oh, I hit another shot?
Oh, I hit a headshot?
Oh, that's not...
Look at that.
I can do it again!
Who's gonna cap though?
No one's gotta, I'm like, gonna cap.
You guys can farm that damage.
Like, oh.
Kobe!
Surely that's not a waste, right?
Oh.
Hey guys, there is a...
Wee-ba!
I'm okay see look at that look at that everything is fine I
climbed see there we go everything's okay I was trying to
clap but then I and then I started shifting instead all
right there you go you did that actually oh they're not
going left right this time they finally learned oh my god no
head height oh
my god maybe not go where I'm coming in do not worry do not
worry there you go All right, the enemy team is pretty bad,
I will say.
All
right, thanks.
Everything is going.
You know what?
I'm going to ult and spawn.
Okay, never mind.
Where is my team?
Like...
Go!
Get him!
Don't worry, we got this!
Oh my god, it's him.
It's...
Wait, where did the... How did the cast die?
That...
Look at that.
So easy.
More damage than the enemy.
Here it go.
I take those.
Most heals and most damage.
I mean, it's 2k, but most damage.
I told you I'll lock in.
Alright, four more thousand.
points to go chat I just need 4k more points to get top out
that's crazy I get top 500 in masters that is so fucking sad
uh squid thank you for super chat thank you thank you great
song to do Scott I don't heard of that song Scotty doesn't
know from your trip never heard of it but thank you for
super chat thank you thank you all right death match all
right here we go look at that we're now even chat we're not
even four to four guys see it's not a negative win right now
guys it's the little things
all right here we go
let's do
what do i want to do i want to do live i won't play die one
game what oh my damage is like so low sometimes I hit every
shot but it didn't matter
what the fuck oh wait is he no it should have been my kill
That should have been my kill.
It was right there.
Select your hero.
The world is so cruel.
It was so lucky.
All right, now I can play Lari.
Dad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My favorite obsessed psychotic.
And I love it when you relapse.
I'm glad you're...
I love it when you're self-destructive.
It's my favorite product, but thank you.
Thank you.
Damn right.
Alright, here we go.
Delari!
Let's go!
Meep, thank you for the five.
chefs thank you thank you i really appreciate it thank you
all right and now swap off them oh and then so oh i'm sorry
for picking elari i and then somebody left they're like no
elari goodbye die i just wanted to play elari
They're like, no, Elari.
Someone will accept my Elari.
Someone will accept it.
Yeah, I don't know how I play Elari.
This is like the third time I played Elari in game.
I think she's not that hard to aim with because it's hit
scan.
Personally.
I don't know how to use her oaks, though.
I will...
Oh my god.
It's a hog-be-hog.
Like...
What?!
Azari?
She's really hard to make...
Like, to make her good.
That's what's wrong with her.
You have to be able to... Because she doesn't... This does
not do a live healing.
Because, uh, this has... It's limited.
So you can't spam it, like, Mora.
So it's like...
But she's really easy to aim with, I personally think.
Oh my god, it's literally hard.
It's not... There's... If NA was not dead, I would have
played Splatoon.
But NA is so fucking... It's not worth it.
Oh my god, it's hazard.
Like, it's... Oh my, get me out of here.
That's so bullshit.
That is so bullshit.
Yeah, you have to be able to get pylons correctly because,
like, you have to be able to place your pylons, like, that
where it doesn't get damage to, like, gear some shit.
But when it's destroyed, it has, like, a 12-second cooldown.
So, she's, like, really hard to make work because you have
to be able to have lots of game knowledge to play there like
feeling like aiming is not hard like i said aiming is not
hard really really oh my god oh my really
but yeah like i said i can't play you can't really do rank
in splatoon only because na is so dead it's so hard to find
games it's not fun at all because you have to play with jp
ping like luckily i'm in west coast so it's not that big of
a deal for me um because i'm in west coast but it's still
annoying playing in uh jp ping for splatoon
why me oh my god literally saves your left stupid see like i
said it's so easy to take down flyers that's a lie
Let's see.
Oh my god.
This Rivey Rive.
And then Vendetta out of nowhere.
Vendetta from downtown of a steel chair.
Sega, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're braver than me for coming back to this game, Doki.
You're seeking other self-destructive competitive games when
I suggest Yu-Gi-Oh.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I've never played card games before.
I've owned a lot of Yu-Gi-Oh cards, but I only owned them
because I thought they were cute.
like not cute but i thought they were cool and cute cool and
cute so like i like the artwork on the cards and i like the
rarity if i it makes me feel good when i pull a rare card so
basically like a pokemon card collector um instead of
collecting pokemon cards when i was growing up i collected
yugioh cards um just because of the yugioh anime so i don't
know how to play any card games uh because of it like i
don't know magic gathering i don't know i play yugioh i
don't know i play pokemon card pokemon um but i know in
yugioh you can literally lose in the first play is a guy has
like a good ass dick
yeah i had the one of the best yugioh collections at my
school people would come would borrow my cards for yugioh
fights yugioh duels for sorry yugioh duels they would
actually borrow they were like can we borrow your cards for
yugioh duels and yeah i would let them like borrow my cards
but yeah i heard like uh yugioh games goals now are like
cats not banned you literally like you just play one game
and then and you can not you can lose lose the game in one
turn and then you have to wait like and then when they do
their turn it takes like five minutes for them to finish
their turn
all right what i want to play alari i don't think you play
alari with cat what do i can you play can alari play with
cat or nah i guess i'll go here i'll find my own path yes
alari tab pick me up it's just hard all right not alari tab
No!
I guess...
Guess it's not a lorry time.
You're gonna come high ground here.
They're on the bastion.
Ooh, have fun.
Ryan, behind you, uh, monkey.
Shut him up.
In the staircase.
What?
Oh, what the fuck?
My pylon already you broke i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it
run on mega i'm gonna do it all right i'm swapping off guys
guys it was tactical because i was gonna swap off regardless
dude did you just pour on me guys guys i wanted to swap guys
I'm with you.
I wanted to swap.
Jesus Christ.
What the?
See, look.
I knew.
I knew I had to swap off.
Right on point.
Oh, I fucked up.
I need help.
You're good to go.
No.
I tried to carry you.
I don't think he's okay anymore.
I don't know we're okay.
He's solo.
Use my tether, Cass!
Nobody knows how to play with a cat because he's always pet.
That's so funny.
Nobody knows how to play with a cat.
He's like, please use my tether.
The Cass just was like, nah.
Round the longer.
Oh my god, he picked him up way and away he goes and away he
goes I pretty much can't let him no You're good.
You're good to me.
He is my daddy Dude, who does this guy think he is?
Nobody looks up apparently
We don't look up in this game.
What is this Marvel rivals?
I believe I'm okay do not worry i'm alive oh guys guys i'm
leaving though i see oh how is he up here make trouble he's
one nice bye oh huge bro huge huge
nice hey guys i'm almost like you guys hey guys hey guys i'm
right here
gamers never look up I feel like Marvel Rivals have more
characters where you have to look up but in this game it's
like nobody looks up because it's so easy to kill flyers in
this game compared to that's right you don't want to look up
here it's a lot easier to kill flyers in Overwatch is he
gonna do come upstairs wait he's coming up wait wait he's
guys he's actually Guys, guys, guys, guys.
Guys, guys.
What the f- What the flaw of...
Why?
I was literally the final gate boss.
Like, I was, I'm in the raid boss.
I was, like, the doorman.
They killed the doorman.
What do you mean?
What can I do?
They killed the doorman.
I was the only one there.
They got the door, man.
I can't do anything about that.
Oh my god, he blocked me with his tree.
That's a devious.
You shout, they passed.
He used nature against me.
Come on, let's go.
Oh, guess not.
Let's not go.
Let's, let's not go, guys.
No, this is a...
I got a kill cut for that.
Oh, did you?
Oh, they're my dub.
Alright, goodbye.
Wait, I'm just a goat.
Wait, I'm no longer the goat.
Do he played deadlock?
I'm so...
I've not touched deadlock yet since...
The very first beta.
Domino.
When it first closed...
The first closed beta where everything was just...
so ugly I don't know it's just it's just a MOBA I just I
don't know I've never played a MOBA before like sorry I got
distracted I got distracted I let myself all right okay okay
I got locked in I'm throwing right now got him I'm mad okay
okay I'm focused for real oh big pal oh Oh, I got locked in.
Oh, my God.
Everything was so good.
I don't know what happened.
Can we touch it?
I'm trying.
I probably could have touched in hindsight.
Okay, we don't like playing quick.
Who minutes on their attack?
This might be a long game.
we just don't we don't like playing point for some reason
right you go it i'm doing it oh my god i mean verticality
won't be an issue i can just taxi you around oh wait they
banana know what he's like i could taxi people but no one
wants to get taxied no one no one fucking picks up the taxi
i'll find my own I just don't I never played a mobile before
and like it's so hard it's it's so hard like the uh like the
builds and stuff give me out give me out give me out let's
go let's go I just get really bored during the during the
mobile section like during the section I'd say before when
we're killing minions and all that i get so bored i just
want to kill them i don't want to kill the minions i just
want to shoot at them but it's all just we all just have to
farm minions and we look at each other while we're farming
minions and it's just like i just yeah what is this like
pussy footing around the farming part i'm just like we're
both just looking at each other just being like oh oh
right now oh we gotta back up am i gonna oh am i gonna try
and kill no no no just here for the minions oh that was all
for the face oh
carry flanking what the oh my god was not huge okay okay i
got lock in i got lock in we tried to curious i can pocket
you if you want to oh yeah i mean we're supposed to poke and
treat but i just wanted i just want a full-on poke no Look
at this guy.
Who the fuck does this guy think he is?
I'm more...
I'm body blocking him.
Get me up there.
Are you serious?
Okay, now I'm like...
I'm actually...
Actually?
Fuck it.
Alright, I'm actually fucking around too much.
That's fine.
Getting him a fire gun in there is good.
Yeah, we actually just made him so scared.
Oh, he's back up there.
We think we're back up.
I think we're back up.
I came down here yet.
I'm keeping my space.
Alright, here you go.
Alright, I got full focus.
I'm actually...
Okay, I get out.
Please pick me up.
Is he getting picked up?
I'm here.
Can't tell.
Look at the ride.
Just keep fighting.
Keep fighting.
Look at this.
I have a lot of us for now.
Oh, my Lord.
Swinging them, swinging them.
I got focused though.
I got hard focused now.
Pick me up.
Let's go.
Where do you want to go?
And it's anywhere.
We're the fighters.
There's...
Oh, I have to push the cart.
I mean...
Get him!
Sacrificial lamb!
Boom!
Kobe!
Oh no, I love that game.
Well, the lamb is fucking sick.
I have yet to play it.
Oh my god, they're like becoming best friends right now.
I didn't even play through Isaac.
I just still need to play through that one.
I'm a cart bitch.
Here I am.
I'd like.
Have you played Mugenics?
I'm cart bitch.
I want to try that.
No, my job.
I'm cart bitch.
Wait, oh my god.
What a rite.
Wait, oh my god, whatever Ryan did.
Big slam.
Whoa.
Fashion top right.
Top right.
Where?
Which rate?
You're a rat or my rat?
I was like, top left, top right.
Which rate is it?
You're a cat in the sky.
I mean, our Ryan literally has a monkey leap.
So that is true.
Get me up there.
On the bridge.
Yeah.
Get me up there.
Oh, hey, guys.
Our backline got pushed.
Don't worry.
I'm sitting up here.
Yeah, I wish that I didn't press E because I thought they
would.
You know when like the rhyme shattered I really thought my
entire team would look behind us and then I could I would
have been able to TP And then they did it.
So I was so confused Tell me how I survived that bro.
Wait huge I I was just surprised he didn't even attempt To
like fucking they did an attempt to look back at me like
Losers went fucking Zenata I was very confused why that
didn't happen.
All right.
I was like, surely they'll look behind me, right?
But then they did it.
Don't we lost one way too early.
That is no point of, never mind, we're even.
Not so fast, like a gentle rain.
They can, I mean.
But huge.
Got a soldier.
Don't give a fuck, it's their private time.
It is true.
You're right.
They're right.
It's their private romance time.
I don't know when we win this.
Yeah, I was going to sit.
How does it look like it?
Do you think I can go to the left side on the coast in C9?
Oh, we can try it.
I'm going to stay here.
Oh.
one you're gonna be down one supporter uh a little bit here
oh is he trying to see nine oh they are can you guys back up
a little bit i'm dead i mean we would love i don't think we
can this would be 10 times fun i don't think we're amazing
guys i think i'm doing it i'm back happening right now.
No, they know.
Bye.
They know.
I don't know what our Samba's doing.
That's for sure.
Oh, we're wasting our advantage here, guys.
I'm just gonna wait here.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go again.
I don't know why we have a Samba, bro.
I don't think the Sombra is working right now.
Oh my god.
Please just hard-pocketing me.
I'm hard-pocketing right now.
Oh, we're both hard-pocketing.
Oh, oh, he countered!
Okay, he's won.
Alright.
Surely this is winnable?
I'm with you.
Peace.
Why are they just suddenly became the best player in the
world?
Yeah, this is definitely not win over.
Now that I got solo kill, I got duo kill.
I got two kills, two solo kills.
I don't know about the Sombra.
Okay, now we swapped off Sombra.
The Sombra might have been like a throw pick for sure.
Oh, very well.
I guess I'll leave now.
He's gonna shatter very shortly.
There's no way it has shattered.
Not yet.
Maybe like a little bit.
Oh, never mind.
No, I didn't hit anyone.
I think it's over.
We're just dying before the launch.
Yeah, we just kept dying.
Yeah, the cast was on the off angle on the right and we
couldn't do anything about it.
Yeah, I don't know why we went fucking somber for two
minutes.
Like our trolled are our shit.
Not me though.
I did my job.
it's okay
I did my job it wasn't me I think if my team if my team
wasn't so distracted with the romance we could have got it
there's a name in this in this lobby though I'm just my team
was familiar looking at right now was so distracted with
their romance novel with their romance here their bromance
it was they were so distracted
so it wasn't me don't you watcher do you want to speak up oh
my other nine minute here
all right here we go guys we'll just try and get back master
one i know we're like let's see if we get gm but you know
let's aim low let's that's a streamer mode name oh that's a
streamer mode name Apparently.
That's a streamer mode name.
I've been, I'm like almost there, guys.
I need a hundred more wins.
And then I'll get, I just need a hundred more wins, guys.
And then, and, and, and then I can actually have streamer
mode.
I'll find my own path.
guys we're almost there a hundred more wins so you can get
it what's a streamer mode name it's just like when you're on
stream so it's like rivals we're like you know we have but
rivals one is not as good for some reason they i feel like
just hide the name forever but in overwatch i like the
system more in overwatch because it hides your name for the
forever rest of the game and then they change your streamer
mode name every time every game you play but they made the
requirement um like harder to get because i used to have
streamer mode and now i don't anymore yeah it gives you a
random name they made the requirement harder like harder to
get you need like an x amount of wins to get it it's very
annoying i i i did my job i did my job i might have to go
break here though it's like it's a problem oh i might go
break Anna is so dead I left her maybe I like it'd be a bit
easier for Anna
so our on and we won't have to worry what the fuck there you
go yeah you like that yeah okay our tracers did
there you go
all right
you're not too oh try
oh my god the double poop oh it's fine it's fine we got it
we both wanted the boot
We both had the same idea.
We're like, I boop and then you boop.
But then we both try to boop at the same time.
Which is not good.
Okay, I'm fine.
No longer.
Oh my!
Okay.
I didn't see the soldier on high ground.
That's unlucky.
It's okay.
We have second life, though.
But I think she might die in second.
life.
Yeah.
Yeah, but.
Oh, I have some lucky.
I might die for it now.
Oh, my eye.
I think I jumped.
I jumped when I shouldn't have.
Oh, it's my shift.
I can boop the Winston away.
Alright, I can use my up.
I don't know.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh my god, I wanted to poop the soldier.
Oh no, should I not play brave?
I'll play something else.
Alright, thank god this is a stream road name because this
would be very embarrassing if someone was actually named
Doki Watcher.
Their own four.
Holy they are!
I feel like I'm doing well.
Doing well on break.
I don't know.
Let's see.
One last diagnostics check can hurt.
Cool go Lucia.
Four, three, two, one.
I'll try to pray for one more day.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, I got you, Anna.
I got you,
Anna!
I got you!
There you go, I got you, Anna!
There we go.
I don't know if I'm doing...
Alright, there we go.
Get... Oh, wait.
What?
That's my range?
I figured out my range in real time, chat.
I...
I figured it out in real time.
I was like, what?
Yeah, I think I'm definitely gonna swap out this guy.
Alright, there you go.
I don't know.
Let's see, whip shots can slam.
Yeah, okay, that's shield bash.
God, I'm not hitting my shift right now.
Guys, I swear to God, I hit all my shifts off stream.
I- Oh shit, I- What?
Okay, I was- I can't believe it.
Wait.
see this how guys i swear to god off stream i hit all my
shield matches it's true guys you should have seen me off
stream oh okay get over here there you go get over here i
got I got you, I saved your life.
I actually did it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's fine.
Where am I?
Where- I can't see!
Holy fuck!
I was like, where did I go?
No, I swear to God.
Every- it's actually insane.
It's insane all my shots hit off stream.
It's crazy.
I'm like it's it's like bam Like I just hit everything.
It's actually wild to see I wish you guys could see it
Oh man when it happens off stream it is like the wildest
thing see it was it's like that is like that Okay, never
mind it's like that
It works just like that, too.
Just like that, but, like, if I hit it.
Like, if I hit it, though.
It works just like that, but what if I hit it?
Okay, I...
He, like, stopped moving.
Okay, but, like, imagine if I hit those shots, though.
Alright.
Imagine, like, but, like, just imagine if I hit...
hit that shift though it's crazy I know it's insane to see
just guys it's crazy to see when I do hit those like off
stream just imagine every shift go crazy too bad I know too
bad it only happens off stream though I know I don't even
know if I should keep playing bring it's just It's sort of
rough.
It's sort of rough.
Okay, maybe...
I'm committing.
It'll work.
It works.
Yeah, are you imagining it?
It's so cool.
I know.
Look, see in your head.
Look in your head, guys, when it works.
Like, in your head.
Can you see it?
your head can you see it guys can you see it oh my god that
wall can see it though
but can you see it though oh
my god can you see that you see that it's sort of like that
it's sort of like that but like what if i hit it it's sort
of But do you see it?
Do you see the vision, though?
You see that vision, right?
You see...
I'm seeing it.
But do you, though?
But do you?
Don't pity see it.
But, like, I need you to actually see it.
Like, not pity.
Like, real.
Real.
You see it.
You see the vision.
Like, like it got me.
Guys, we're weird.
What the fuck?
Okay,
that cast was fucking crazy for that.
Let me grab my glasses.
Okay, I do think I should swap, but I have ult soon.
I- I- I touched him.
Do you guys see it?
I sure did.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're running.
We're leaving here.
All right, here we go.
This is it.
I can use my ult here.
All right, this is it.
This is it.
Right here!
Oh my god, do you see the vision?
The vision!
It's right...
The vision is right here!
That was a good burgote.
See, look at that!
That advice are good.
See?
There's the vision.
The vision is right there.
I don't know if the Reaper ult still stuns.
If the Brick is still stun a Reaper ult.
So like...
There you go.
Oh, oh.
You saw that, though.
Oh, I fucked up.
I definitely fucked up.
And I think he nanowed me.
Okay, look.
all right so now I'm Lucio we actually here is better
actually all right okay that's that's awkward that was a
little awkward it's okay now I'm on Kiri guys I'm on Kiri I
wanted to die there so I could swap oh that's that's awkward
for I didn't expect her to nano me, but we might not have a
nano anymore.
And they have a reprill for the last fight.
Which is very scary.
Oh my god, I can't.
I couldn't.
I was trying to get my...
Dude, our DPS were fucking doo-doo.
God.
This has never lived.
Guys.
I might I should have swapped off a break earlier I I should
have swapped off a break earlier the Anna believe in the
vision though okay look the Anna shouldn't have ulted me I
don't know why she did that guys look I think look the Anna
we all made mistakes here not just me the did that of me and
lost the up that de on the on look deanna believed a bit too
much in the vision guys she might have believed in it too
much in the vision i should have swapped up brazier in a
third round when they were on too that one shield bash
actually cost the game i didn't think that one shield bash
could have made everything fall apart i really didn't I
think they would, that would have happened.
I didn't think that it would lead to a domino effect of all
of it just falling apart.
Gus, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
First you buy the dog, now you judge them.
Thank you for super chat, thank you, thank you.
Sin, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm finally playing my favorite game after this long day.
Doki said excitedly.
um she then met those the most sweatiest the most bitchless
unemployed creatures in this planet losses nope nope no it's
wait what's the record it's like four something it's four
five or is it four six right now is i have four five or four
six i don't remember give me death match i will i'll take
partial blame but this is a teen game
This was a king.
I will take partial blame.
There you go.
See?
I think I was like...
He's fun.
She's fun to aim with.
Oh, he got rid of my pylon.
Oh, you're scared now.
Wait, what the fuck?
Get out of here, guys.
Get out of here.
Okay, come on.
Come on!
That's a 1v2.
That was a 1v2.
Come on.
Alright, here we
go.
This time, this is Lari time.
choose heroes to ban this is it i now now i can play larry
guys i swear to god i climb a lot off i swear off stream
doki she's insane guys i swear off stream doki wow she she
goes hard off stream doki is like a whole new level of doki
i
It's crazy.
Oh, gross.
I didn't want this skin.
I don't want her to be dead.
That's going to seal my fate.
I just want to know what that skin was called.
A pre-recorded token.
Let's finish this quickly.
Alright.
This is the first game of Valari.
Third game of my life.
Third Alari game of my life.
Let's go.
How?
What could go wrong?
Alright, here we go.
Watch off-streaming Doki do her thing.
Whoa, what?
What the fuck?
Why did it so...
Oh my god, I missed the shot when I shouldn't have missed
it.
I shouldn't have missed that shot.
Whoa.
I shouldn't have missed that shot on Sojourn.
I was so confused.
I was like, where is the team?
Like, in a high ground?
Oh, my pylon's doing its job, though.
Look at that.
He's doing his job.
He's working very hard.
My pylon's working very hard, though, healing everybody.
I'm just gonna...
oh no that was my entire pot trap I think I have to go Kyrie
actually I don't have
oh my god
that's good nice oh
shit wait what do I get though trees oh wait I should get
that oh
my god okay oh my god hello there we go that's right it's
just weird to not have like a lot of mobility i mean do have
a but you know what i mean like i mean by that
five no she saw it
i don't know how to use this all correctly
oh god no that's bad that's bad why did she ask me why
why did you ask me
why did she ask me i was like why why did you it's like You
know like when you get nanoed?
It's like panic.
You know what I mean?
I was like, I wasn't expecting that.
I was expecting the nano.
Oh shit, I should've fucking healed that.
It's like it's like the panic button where you're like I'm
getting nanoed.
You know?
She saw the vision.
Apparently I didn't.
I didn't see the vision she was looking at.
I didn't see it.
I didn't see that.
vision oh
god how does she always see it
oh god thank you oh
god please tell me i'm near my own pylon yes i am oh my god
i was near my own pylon that they don't know they don't know
they don't see the pilot they don't know see it the vision
is there the vision is there
all right here we go
here we go there's no way he sees that what is this oh i
think this is good right
does she see the vision i'm looking at oh Oh my god, there's
a car behind me!
Okay, I'm gonna wait for him to- Okay, there we go.
Here we go.
It's fine.
What the?
Okay.
Oh god, please.
Oh my god, the vision!
The vision!
The- Shit!
The vision was there.
We all saw the vision.
It was there.
I saw it.
We all saw it, right?
We all saw the vision.
Yeah, we saw it!
I saw it!
I knew it!
I knew we saw it!
I knew!
Vision that...
It's worked!
My pylons!
My pylons were good!
My pylons were pretty sick!
Greetings!
Chills!
I saw the light!
the new atom skin where he's fucking naked and he's wearing
like his boxers on his head like the fucking ugliest atom
like not even just the ugliest atom skin the ugliest skin in
all of them marvel rams and a scientist maybe that's a bad
pylon what would be a baby here yeah i wish i had like his
little dance where he like rubs his feet on the floor Wait,
that sounds weird, but I meant like the one foot.
Like he's like, do the little twist.
I didn't mean to sound sus.
That's pretty.
It sucks.
Oh my god.
So low.
Nice.
All right, it's fine.
Why is that a different count?
Because his only roles that's in range with me is support
and dps his main role is tank surprisingly his main role in
overwatch is tank because apparently he's done like he's
playing on the overwatch world cup right now and plays on
tank and
he got tired of all the shitty tank players we kept getting
whoa whoa whoa whoa my pylon's not gonna save you from
headshot What?
That's fine.
And he got my pylon too?
He got a tooper?
I'm coming back.
It's double sniper so it's so hard to play around.
Those one percent.
For Iana, he's dead.
Oh fuck, okay.
I'm staying here.
Oh, my baby.
I'm scared.
You guys can go in through.
My pylon!
Johnny, Johnny, I need the nano.
Thank you, Johnny.
Bye.
It's okay.
I'll know the range fully.
And you figure out the range for, like, the heal.
I know it's long, but, like, half.
How long though?
I should swap.
I'm not making as much impact as I was before.
Oh my god.
Hello, it's just me.
Yeah!
Oh That was a good hide
Oh shit, okay, that's awkward
Bam!
Oh shit Oh shit, wait, it still hit her It's still, there's
a vision Oh shit, not that though
There was a vision There it is!
Oh no!
They broke it.
God.
It hit her!
She got hit with the sun!
I saw the sun on her!
I saw the sun!
I swear I saw it.
Oh my god, I could have...
I did kill it.
look at that look at that guys oh shit our piranha but it
worked
no way she sees this I
told you that guy's crazy for that for peaking that I like
to hear the widow here but where
I see.
Oh.
Why?
Here we go.
Here's your pylon.
Junker coin on our Anna.
There you go.
There's...
I told...
See?
It works.
Like, I don't know why the life weaver got close.
Like, bro was cooking.
He was cooking.
He was like, this is it.
Watch this, I got the high ground as he like gets near me.
You know what, maybe?
Maybe he'll come over.
Yeah, look, look at that.
Look at that.
I'm ready for the nano.
Wait, what?
Let's go.
Okay.
Let's get the nano going.
Get nano going.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
There's a no, I'm here.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, where the...
Oh!
I'm okay.
I have my own little pylon.
There we go.
Okay.
We can do this to get it.
Oh my god!
He was one!
He was actually one!
Holy shit, okay, okay, but I almost got him one though.
I almost got him one.
He doesn't see it.
He saw it.
Okay, wait.
Right here.
Z9!
I got him though!
I got him.
I got more damage than the other widow.
Oh, do you know what?
Yeah!
See?
Lari's not so bad.
Look at that.
My DPS not so bad on the Lari, chat.
5k just pile on healing.
Still what?
The vision?
I told you.
The vision!
Oh, that wasn't expected.
I mean, it felt like it.
It really did.
Look at that.
It's easy to...
I feel like Alara is really easy to aim.
Aim with her.
Whoa.
Wait a minute.
Am I seeing what I'm seeing right now?
does she all uh wait oh that hides
depends on the skin depends on the skin old man thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you where are you looking
at all you weren't it's all right you're you're you have a
good you're good you're a good person you're in You are
you're so innocent.
I'm gonna use the bathtub.
We're back
I'm back it's time I could do it again I'm sure some would
disagree like the sniper it's time I saw Fabelari if it
doesn't work that well I think Lari's fun.
I mean Lari's like DPS support.
Lari, I can actually, like you guys could saw, like I can
actually shoot with Lari.
You can actually aim with her.
Fucking, I actually hit my shots.
Kierko, it was like, it was a little messy there.
Kierko.
Kierko was, mmm, not so much.
Because that, that should heal.
That range should be fun.
What?
Already?
Like, I got that headshot, though.
Come on, come over here to help our Anna.
Oh no, my pylons broken.
I don't know what to do now.
Wait, where is this?
Oh, okay.
That's right.
There we go.
Let's hope he doesn't see the pylon.
It's right there.
Where is it?
Hanzer.
Oh my god, he saw my pylon!
How?
It's fine.
I got this.
I'll do here.
That sucks.
They all keep seeing my pylon!
Oh, this is bad.
Yeah.
Oh
Put it here for now Oh,
no, he has they hacked our health pack.
That's not good
All right, goodbye But not like that I didn't I didn't okay,
I mean I thought I'd still be alive, but He stepped on all
your and you're all you He got pissed at me when I ulted and
like just me and miss goodbye actual goodbye not like that
though bro he keeps i can't i don't know what to do for a
second here hold on oh my god this hondo is breaking my
angles we have no score right now all right i'm swapping i
can't they keep breaking all my pylons
Wait, they have no support either, you're good shit.
Up top, soldier.
I'll find my own spot.
It's fine.
No, I missed it.
We're coming back, just live!
No!
No, soldier and one HP on the stairs on the right.
Go for him.
He's one!
No!
I tried!
I almost got Kyrie.
It wasn't one!
Alright, now go to Q.
That was a lie.
That was a fucking lie.
There's a soldier in who is heart-stacking himself and
excited.
That was not one!
I was here, you know.
I have to swap off.
They keep hitting all, every pylon existence.
I didn't know what to put my pylon.
Is he okay?
He's okay.
JQ coming up a lot of it right now.
Right here a little bit.
I'm okay as well.
Oh, not him, though.
Choose one.
Nice.
I need to farm this though.
Oh no.
I have no shield.
They have no supports.
They should be able to...
Never mind.
She's low enough.
She's black.
I'm trying too.
Oh my god.
That's unlucky.
Oh, the fallout.
I really need my perk though.
He has all up though.
Holy shit, I don't know where to go.
I don't...
All right, I don't have to unlock the second perk yet.
Really don't want to.
And I just unlocked, like, her, she should have second perk
while I'm close.
Because I unlocked my first perk, because I swapped.
But she never swapped.
Oh, I can't.
Okay.
We'll wait until our Giva pushes.
It's not as good if our Ana still is on first perk.
Me on first perk is fine because I just, I swapped for her
on first perk.
Not so bueno.
Oh fuck it, let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Okay, well, she countered.
Okay, then.
Have to keep this, okay.
trying to keep my suzu because they have that.
That's good.
I suzued it.
Alright.
Please.
No!
Oh, nice, nice.
Our turret guy.
It's okay.
They don't... They have... They have... They have Ana.
But it's okay!
It's not okay.
It's no longer okay.
It's okay!
It's okay now.
It's no longer...
We're so back!
It's okay.
It's so...
We're so back!
I almost have my second perk!
3 for 1?
1?
Okay.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Oh my god, why did you jump off?
It's bad that he jumped up.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Everything is okay.
We're so back.
It's over.
It's so over.
We're so back.
Gamers, don't look up.
Have you guys been listening to Invincible or watching it?
Negative.
I mean, I didn't want to just let it sit in silence.
I wanted to respond to it.
I know I have no thank you thank you for that the turret was
the oh excuse me but I healed that turret yeah because some
people are usually on their fucking phones and they don't
care about other people's you know words guys but who was
healing the turret you know I healed the tor that healed the
turret yeah white people I swear to God I'm sure he's just
no not that no not that
believe.
I messed through a little with being Lari, but I've always
believed.
Just a little bit.
Look, even when they destroyed all my pylons, I still did a
pretty decent amount of healing.
Now imagine if they did steal my, like...
Okay, look, that...
Rush start.
Oh, they're all the same.
Look, okay, um...
I was looking at my chat.
I was That was my bad.
This guy might be a better sim player than, like, might be a
better Kiriko player than me.
Maybe.
He might be better at Kiriko.
Right.
Oh, we're even now.
Anna's sitting out in the open.
Hey, look at this guy.
Make sure everybody is healed, though.
Okay, that hit.
So sure.
Z?
No, he's not okay.
Actually, I think Winston is gonna hold on.
Alright.
That's okay.
It is shot early.
We priored that.
Oh my god.
i did not expect him to die so fast
how come we how come we go off lucy oh the lucy pick was
really good okay it's fine
all right here you go okay that's your goal is better better
at doing this than me rush because i i don't know how to she
knows my head height and you're done all right she knows my
head height I don't
oh my god let's go with Kiri rush here around the corner oh
we know you're not here I'm here now I'm here now do it
let's do it go with the point I know he is oh my god oh my
god all right
Well, hmm, this does not look like a win chat I would this
does not look like a win when you got the hover Is the hover
even good?
I thought the other one was good not the hover He still has
the junker you know, and I'm scared You're gonna I have to
keep my Oh
One oh, there we go We got it, we got it, please go back to
Lucio.
It's a lot easier Please is she and yeah he is All right,
this is lose a book This is under free
Man, I wish a new head level like here like that other gear
throw that's right he didn't grab me i don't think he wants
to swap the lucio guys
what the weapons out
all right
what the okay i did not expect that guys can you shoot the
thing that'll be pretty neat you're an ltp wait that's in
the blood nice oh i almost killed him he was so low oh my
god okay i didn't think i tp into his gun i didn't give a
second point for free all right
into the goddamn pistol okay i was like i should should be
fine it's just one guy and it's more than just one guy
counter watch i thought it's a lot of fun personal jq love
on point i think you're sure oh nice we one point for this
kiri this kiri is she's just she's kiri diffing me guys i i
I won't sugarcoat it.
I'm getting Kiri diff right now.
She's a better Kiri.
She is 100% a better Kiri than me.
Kiri all.
Oh my god.
She is so good.
She's been playing Kiri for 20 years.
And I've been playing everything but Kiri.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Yeah, that was actually just so unlucky.
Did you hear that?
Oh.
That Reaper is close to alt now, though.
He's bad.
There you go.
Oh my god, oh that's fine, it's just Torb.
It's just Torb.
I baited, that was a bait, guys.
That was a clear bait.
No, no.
Speak your, speak your shit, King.
Speak your shit.
I don't like her.
She's not very nice The sojourn is one sojourn is one HP
Job team That's my bug I was stuck like I saw that guy is so
big I need to get him get him go All right, yay Yeah, he did
it where did you I thought they got him Look at that.
See you guys Everything she might I have more damage.
I have more Damage she might be better at me than Kira but I
have more damage And one more kill Than her I think she
farmed This place sucks.
Oh my god 50% of that damage from me alone We're still back
I have more damage guys I and One damage more One kill more
than her end i might be better i'm in the end i might be
better guys there's still hope
she yeah exactly oh wait that's such a nice genji skin wait
a minute that skin's pretty pretty neat vote for your map
like why is this game alive i want to go buy i want to buy
emotes how are we insecure how dare this game be not dead
select your hero
choose hero bands all right here we go here we go see the
longer you play the better you get chat i see it i see it
just gotta keep playing the more you play you might be be
losing games now, but keep on going.
You'll eventually win.
Alright, Master's 5 or Master 1.
That's not so bad.
Alright.
I'm actually having fun with a lot.
Maybe this time they won't shoot my pylon.
Maybe this time.
I don't really like this skin, but it's been I've been
winning, so.
I've been winning with the skin, so maybe Maybe it'll work.
Maybe it'll work.
That is a mighty fine rifle.
Mind if I give it a world?
That's right.
99% of gamblers quit before they hit it big.
99% of rank grinders quit before they hit it big.
Alright, here we go.
Whoa.
Oh my god, you know, like he tried, you know?
Like it was a nice attempt.
There you go.
We can...
Here we can...
Can we shoot it?
Where is he?
See, he doesn't see it.
Oh my god, he's won.
Oh my god, I'm so...
Oh wait, we're flipping it.
We're flipping it.
We're flipping our...
Look at us.
Go!
Whoops.
I don't know.
That's good.
I think that's a pretty bad pilot.
All right, I'll put it here.
There's no way he sees him.
Whoa, all right.
They're up here.
Yeah.
Boom.
That's right!
They're not gonna see this pylon.
I don't think they're up here anymore.
Oh, unless...
Don't worry, they don't see this one.
Where are they going?
Over where?
Are they still... Where are they going?
What is the plan?
I don't know what the plan is.
Alright.
Whoa, whoa, I'm gonna be here, guys.
Oh, wait, wait, we got...
Okay.
What the fuck?
What is that?
I mean, we got the point.
Like, I just was like, nano, I'm like, where's the nano?
Teleports behind me.
He was right there.
Where were we where?
Right there.
Sneaky, sneaky.
It's because he doesn't use his legs.
He's like the hardest to hear out of all the characters
because he fucking floats.
Nothing, personal kid.
Okay, my pylons were pretty juicy.
They're pretty juicy, guys.
There you go.
Lightspeed!
Oh shit, nice.
Oh my god, they discovered it.
Oh my god, guys, I think it's...
I think it's...
I think it's time to retire.
They were tired.
The character.
He found my pylons.
I don't know what to do when they find it.
There you go.
I got...
Okay.
I think they found out where I put my pylons, guys.
They're learning.
They're actually learning.
They're figuring it out.
Oh shit, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, I had to kill him!
I'm sorry!
No, my pilot!
I had to ego that.
I think I'm better at...
Oh god, but who's gonna see?
No!
That's alright.
hilarious they're scared they're fucking scared oh shit uh
dada they have a super chat they can thank you they figured
it out i'm wearing pylons here how do they keep fucking
discovering my pylons
i don't understand they keep figuring it out Okay, they
won't figure out this pylon.
We gotta peek first, bitch.
Oh, never mind.
There's no way they figure it out.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
Where's my pylon?
Oh, no.
I'm worth it.
what the fuck all right there we go let's go let's go i'm
better i'm better illari oh she has more damage but i'm
better not even let's guys guys i have more healing than the
other illari that's all that matters Even though Elari is
about DPS, it's a...
Guys, I have more kills, too.
Guys, I have more kills than the enemy Elari.
I might just be a Lari player.
The fuck here it goes.
It's like forcing myself to be a Kiri main.
I might just...
You know what?
Master 1!
Let's go!
Guys, I just...
Maybe I'm just an Elari player.
Maybe I just...
Maybe Elari is just for me.
I think I found it.
It's like I'm trying to force myself to be a Kiri player.
But all along, I was just in Elari, man.
Look at that.
We got our rank back.
It's possible.
See, guys, it is possible.
Alright, here we go.
I don't want to play with yet.
I never wanted to play with her.
I...
No, he's taking Alari from me.
I never wanted to.
I was just forced into it.
I actually... I actually hit my shot... Oh, no.
I actually hit my shots on Alari.
on Kiriko.
I fucking hate it.
That's trash.
You just patting Kiriko.
No!
You're not even an Aari player.
You don't even play a Aari.
What?
Ooh.
Who is it?
Scared up, girl.
Oh, wait, her name.
They might try something.
I want to win.
He got to Texas tuck those pylons better, Doki.
Star, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't want to be scared.
I want to fucking win.
Bro, this guy is not even a fucking Allari.
He just takes Allari from...
He's scared of girl.
Oh, what am I?
My friend talked to you once a long time ago.
And then you like got really scared of her.
Yeah, it happens, I'm gonna be honest.
Aura Mori was like, hey, and then you like got freaked out.
Ah, no, no, no, no, don't say that name.
Okay, well, I won't say that.
I won't say their name.
Sorry, sorry, I forgot you scared of girls.
I forgot, sorry.
I wanted the, why would you see that now you give him
trauma?
Now he's thinking about his trauma.
So you're telling me, if a girl talks right now, you would
get scared.
Well, yeah, Juggernaut's already over before it started.
What if it was like an MP4 player?
all right spidey senses don't sense it don't tingle when
it's baked i need some help what the fuck i thought the
emery was right behind me but he wasn't
i thought i had my emery to protect me so i was like i
should be fine emery is like right here
My T.P.
was on him.
My T.
Okay.
It's fine.
It's zoning.
I'm...
It's just a zone.
It's a zone.
How is it still me?
How does that hit me?
How did that hit me out of everybody?
Oh, why do they want me so bad?
How did it still hit me out of everyone?
I guess I'll move the payload on payload bitch
We don't worry this will these papers will travel Believe
See my paper will eventually fly oh jesus christ The paper
will eventually fly over.
That's the great thing about paper.
It keeps flying.
Look at it go.
Look at, I'm a good...
The cart princess.
Just like my Lucio days.
Look at that.
Well...
Look at that!
What?
Is it fine?
It's so fine.
I
don't know what it is.
Yeah, it's still fine.
It's definitely still fine.
Just...
Look at that.
I told you.
Raise her no recall.
Ooh.
this or no recall oh i didn't get it you got it here all
right you get scared of like the girl characters or no hello
or are you like built in immunity i'm used to it right now
you got used to it especially like you actually adapt that's
actually cool like evolve yeah man like a pokemon here is
gone I can lay like a Pokemon.
Alright, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is so healthy.
But not for him.
It's okay.
Oh, he's so low, too.
Don't worry.
Our Emory's got him.
Okay, I don't know where the fuck he went.
I mean, that's smart.
At the back of the cart, you never expected on the cart, you
know?
because you're like that's too obvious you know like how
could it be on the oh never mind they expected it on the
back of the car never mind they expected it all right what
do we let's die here
let's just die here
all right i should have up soon
That's crazy, because you would expect the pylons to be
higher ground, but he puts the pylons on low ground.
It's like, you know, you just never expect it, you know?
That's how little you expect it, you're like, there's no way
this pylon would be on the ground.
That's, that's crazy.
And then it is, like, like, who would, oh, okay, the pylons
gone.
Oh, recall, right there.
Okay, never mind, the pylons already gone.
Okay, don't.
That's our high ground.
Never mind.
What the fuck?
Hello.
The guy's name is Tubby.
Get him.
Get Tubby.
Right here.
I think so.
Whoa!
I don't know if I want to be over there.
It says this.
It ends.
I don't want it to end yet.
No.
neither a little scared there he said it ends and i got
scared what if it doesn't my emory just got three kills off
people i headshot right before he just blasted them like all
right yeah i don't i mean it is a team-based game you know
nah bro i just got him play the game not even trolling
sworn your master's too so only when we win guys yeah your
your shits more matter only when we win guys i don't want to
scare him and then we lose
that's not bueno i care about winning more than more than
scaring this poor man do you have like a six sense if there
is a like like a girl on the
right now.
There is one among us.
Oh my god, there is.
What?
Who is it?
Oh my god, he knows.
You can feel it.
You can feel the women.
I suppose you are more fortunate than most.
Who is it?
Or am I wrong?
I don't know.
Who is the woman?
Who could it be?
You're the one that's like the expert.
Don't you lie to me.
I know about you, alright?
What do you mean?
Hold on, hold on.
Hold on.
I know about you.
No, you don't.
I don't know.
I'm on to you.
Oh, it's the Illari, isn't it?
I bet you it's the Illari.
I don't know who else it could be.
Who else could it be?
It has to be the Illari.
Holy shit.
Okay.
That's actually a wild hit.
That's wild.
That's a wild rollout that that guy made.
I need to get out of here.
I don't like being that close to Doomfist.
Bro, his blinks is so...
Okay, we're like giving so much free space, though.
I don't like it.
Don't worry, I kill those.
Oh my god.
They were so talented.
Yeah.
Hey, yeah, I didn't say I was gonna kill her and live, but I
killed her.
Oh my god, I'm insane!
I always forget, like, if it's left or right at first.
But...
Alright.
Alright, please hold.
Setting up a rollout.
Kill the junker out with wings.
I'm ready for it.
Alright.
Let's do it.
Oh, that's...
Oh my.
Oh my god.
I just got punched into a bolt bomb.
Alright.
Okay, I think that's a bit too much.
I think, okay, okay guys.
Okay, that might be...
Um...
For one...
One fucking...
Don't worry, I'm coming back with another rollout.
For one fucking ulting Doomfist.
That might have been a throw.
Man, I wish we had...
I sure wish we had another ulter for this.
All that matters is that I kill the bearer, right?
I...
I sure wish we had more ults.
I got injured in midair.
He had it coming.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, bro.
Yeah, but he like shot that shit.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I was like, guys.
Oh, my God.
I just rocked or fart in the air, and I couldn't hit him.
I'm pissed.
That'd be too easy.
You're right.
We can't make this game too easy, guys.
Alari, you're actually banned from playing that character.
Stop shooting the Doomfist.
I was wondering why he was getting so many punches.
Yeah, not me though, I would never I would never
That one step was very crucial You don't understand
It's okay, it's okay We have a lorry We have a Bro, why does
she always put it on the ground It can't always be good It
can't I don't feel I don't I don't know like I'm starting to
doubt her ground Pilots, I don't know me isn't me?
Is it me?
I just feel like that this is about to be the biggest hire
of all time I feel like There's no way there's no way Musuki
one Like, look at this.
What is this pylons?
Like, like, like, does he know that pylons can attach to the
walls?
Like, what, what are these pylons?
I don't understand.
I, I, I, I, I, what are these pylons?
There's walls.
Oh my god, wait.
I have to be getting enrage.
We need it.
Like I don't!
Stop!
That's embarrassing for you.
Okay, both support alts gone for them.
Maybe we use one.
Let's go!
Alright, we only have one support alts now.
Oh!
I have killed two people.
Damn it.
Carry me, father.
Yes, son.
Oh, hey, what?
He ignored me.
Let's go.
As you wish.
Wait, Tubby switched off Farah and he had Barrage.
There you go.
Look at that.
He never used it.
All right, Tubby's out of town.
They ignored me.
They ignored me, guys.
You see?
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
No, I'm not.
Oh my god, you go.
Oh my god.
He still got inside Oh, I'm done.
I'm not done.
Oh my god.
It's so over.
Oh, it's so over.
Why is he still on the ground?
Why is this still on the ground?
I don't even think so.
I actually, I had so many mixed like, like full of emotions.
Damn, I was really having fun slamming tubby out of the air.
What am I supposed to do for content now?
Like, what?
Damn.
We all had fun slamming tubby.
It was a party.
Hello, I leave now.
Cool.
I did absolutely nothing.
Free win.
That was pretty cool.
Oh yeah, let's look at this.
Let's watch their health.
bars paid what did you do other health bars for me wait what
girl did you not just hear that i told you there was one
among us bro there was one
oh my god we're finally positive
he knew he fucking knew he had the sixth sense was quiet he
was quiet for a second bro i i need it okay i need a i have
to see this all right where is this guy this is larry oh god
damn i need to know i he wasn't scared yeah he's not as
scared as i thought he was no that that larry i was just
like why is every time i looked at the pylon it's on the
ground i swear to god I've not seen a single I don't
understand
Alright here we go
Mercy Where the fuck has been Mercy On King's Row I mean
King's Row is a good mercy map actually it is Alright it's
time It's my lorry time
Ring ring Lorry Lorry's here Ring ring
i can't believe i've been playing over watch for like almost
six hours it does not feel like i'm sorry guys it does i
we're back to the basement two six hour streams in a road oh
my god okay all right there's time ring ring ring come this
is the woman oh man thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you said thank you for this but cosmo thank you for
the five gifted ships thank you thank you all right boom
nobody will expect this pylon
yo it's just crazy the confidence he had to fucking put the
pylon on the floor like oh no there we go found vendetta
zarya oh no wait i that's no I don't want to deal with that
oh my god they like yeah I'm done here I need help no you're
not no you're not oh my god my pylon okay you are dead now
for real okay my pylons god you might be dead oh my god this
is actually scary
okay I have to swap off vendetta i'm gonna actually have to
swap off another i'm not hitting right now no one i'm not
hitting there's too many people on lying everywhere oh
unless
where oh
oh my god these Oh my god, I'm a noob.
I just, I got the wrong perk.
Oh my god, I'm a noob.
Oh my god, please help me.
It's okay, my pylon is still off, baby!
My pylon!
My pylon is still off, baby!
It's still off!
I've done 200 damage!
But my pylon's MVP!
Ha ha ha ha!
It's doing God's work right now.
It's actually doing God's work.
The vendetta is coming.
She's coming with all...
She really is.
I'm not gonna...
Alright, there you go.
It's alright.
It's not okay anymore.
But my pylon!
Oh my god, please kill the Zarya.
Oh god.
My word.
My pylon, with God's word!
My pylon's finally dead.
My pylon, after 20 years, I finally died.
I, you know, I'm just a surprise by how long that lasted.
I...
It lasted the entire round.
That was crazy.
Wait, can I not can I not pooch the netta against the wall?
Wait, what?
Oh, I just learned something.
Oh my god, my pylons.
It's okay.
I still have additional pylons.
I should put it on the ground, troop.
Troop.
Get over here, yes!
There you go.
That's crazy.
I already have a second perk.
Boom!
Nobody expects a skypile on.
I told you, nobody expects it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That was embarrassing.
What happened?
I couldn't get it.
I think I got it.
I gotta swap though.
I might need a swap.
Guys, stay here.
I don't know if we can touch though.
Oh, we're not touching.
You, uh, nano me here, Anna?
Whenever I go in here?
Hold on, wait.
Never mind, we don't need it.
It's okay.
My pylons gone is no longer okay.
Okay, wait.
Hi, God!
There you go.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
I have a lot of heals.
Not a lot of damage, but it's okay.
I swear, if they go Reaper, I swear they're gone.
Oh, my God.
They went fast.
Oh, that's what I'm talking about.
It's okay.
All right, just walk him out of my car.
Just walk him.
Don't heal him.
I don't I can't do something else I could do
It's okay guys The pylon still lives Somehow The pylon is
still alive It's okay The pylon they don't know where it is
It's still alive
It's still alive It's still alive We couldn't be hiding if
you won my help
You don't see it right but you saw it they actually saw it
there's the pylons gone guys
Kind of you and i we're gonna do the ground pylon thing it
didn't work it didn't He finally saw the pylon right now i
get punched
Holy shit
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna stop playing Larry it might not I'm
doing a lot of healing though I'm yes let's lock in we got
this all right no one expects the ceiling I okay I'm gonna
say I did not 10k healing on Lari only.
Okay, now I definitely can't play Lari.
Now I definitely can't play Lari.
That one's said.
Not exactly.
It's a DPS issue.
Not an Lari issue.
I'll find my own path.
Yeah, for some reason, the ground pylon was not as good as
this guy.
The fact that my pylon did so much for so long, like...
That's crazy.
The fucking...
My pylon lived for so long in that first fight.
In the first...
In that first point.
It just stayed alive.
Nobody shot it.
That was insane.
I was not expecting that.
That pylon was carrying my fucking soul.
My entire team on its back, including me.
I was not hitting shit.
but that pylon carried my entire team including me there I
did not know what the fuck I was doing I should definitely
batten venerator though what the
fuck are Zen
sorry one HP is okay sorry it's still one HP is he still 1
HP.
It should still be 1 HP, right?
There we go.
Everything is fine.
Pylons never die.
Why is there like two of us on there?
I see three.
Who is not standing?
I was like...
I was like, I swear to God.
I see three of us on point.
Somebody is just like fucking vibing outside of the point.
While standing next to us.
Like, why would you do that?
Ooh.
Oh, I gotta heal myself now.
Wait, somebody's up on high ground.
I knew it.
I heard it.
Guys, let's walk in.
I have my own.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, I need to reload.
Azaria has all two and on.
Oh, wait.
Zen.
We have Zen.
And they don't have an Ana.
So like, what are they gonna do?
Nothing!
Alright, it's fine.
Some buddies are... Oh, okay, never mind.
Yeah, I guess I'll push.
Don't worry, I'll be cart bitch again.
Oh, it's the cart bitch.
No.
Pushback tubby.
Never the other thing.
I mean, we do have Xeno for the Zarya grab.
I was going to say, there is no way we can die.
Will they be able to?
If we push up, maybe.
I feel at the moment they try to backcap, it's okay to get
in here and he's just a little guy oh it's not gonna whack
goodbye Zed we lost like 20 seconds goodbye Zed who would I
thought the back cap did not work I
don't know where his hit where this guy's head is Jesus
Christ oh my god I don't know how I can save him I don't
know how I can save him either.
Okay, I save you though.
Do I?
Haha!
Never mind.
He has way too much energy.
How does Azaria have so- Oh, that's why.
Y'all, let's walk in.
I got my own.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Oh no, guys.
This doesn't look
This doesn't look very optimal.
Oh no.
Man, we left this dog shit open up and dead as Arya.
God damn it.
Why do we have mercy?
That's a good question.
Okay, that's not on me.
He peaked.
He peaked when he shouldn't have.
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, I don't know.
Oh, he's gonna...
He's gonna...
There it is!
I was like, alright!
Um, didn't know about the trends there.
I didn't mmm that mmm I hope he's swapping nope he's not
swapping he's not swapping characters he's not it's not
swapping out of Zen oh I'm seeing is that I think that was
it oh
it's fine Whoa, that's five.
Oh, that is no longer five.
They have fun.
Okay, I...
Okay, it's okay.
No longer five.
Hmm, that vendetta has all...
I don't feel very good about that.
Last but...
Hold up.
Holy shit, he speared it!
Wait, that's hardcore.
That's actually hardcore.
He speared it.
For those who didn't see it,
I'm heal-bottling the shit out of this right now.
Alright, nice.
See you guys?
Doesn't hurt to have...
Transfer.
Look at that, guys.
Is he still fighting the Juno?
Oh, okay.
Let's get the payload going.
All right, here we go.
Most likely we're going to be fighting for a draw though,
which is, unless we like, hard steamroll this.
Which is still possible.
It is possible to do it.
We gotta do it here.
All right, never mind.
I don't know what that Kirill was.
Never mind.
I didn't think they would hard push all of us.
All right, never mind.
It's either a draw.
Oh.
I didn't think we were all going to back up, to be fair.
I didn't think we were all going to leave.
gotta see you know what flip you know what flip oh oh i
tried goodbye zen
goodbye look i did have a feeling that this game was not it
but
hasn't been eight hours we're at six of the game
look that wasn't on me though i know that for sure
it's never on me except except for that last alt that last
thought i just didn't think that everybody was gonna back
off like back out so i was like all right goodbye again and
that we're all gonna push forward i was like whoa all right
let's i guess i guess we'll all
what even is let me check what is america it's 5 800 child
it's that's so i can literally i feel like i just can just
play for a week and hit it so stupid i feel like i really
feel like just play for a week and then just hit it there
it's not that too difficult to even to even thousand this
guy's not stopped how long has he been playing for
that's rank one
there's there's such a fucking gap like no one's gonna hit
it no one's gonna reach it like actually no one's gonna
reach it how how far is he 28 hours like that's like half of
this man's hours this guy's hours bro it is like he's been i
feel like he's been playing 10 hours a day at this point
select a map it's like he was playing 10 hours a day
select your hero all right here we go i'm ready
choose hero bands
oh wait i'm banning vendetta After last time.
What is it?
Diva, Vendetta.
Uh.
Oh, fuck.
I don't know what the third one is.
Oh, it's fine.
We got it.
I'm just not enjoying the current rival's meta.
I feel like I'm getting...
Also, I think I'm...
I feel like I'm getting better.
Oh, wait.
She plays Alari.
Alright.
I'll give you Alari.
I'll be nice today.
Look at that.
See?
I'm a nice person.
I'll find my own path.
I feel like I'm getting my mechanical skills are improving
more playing Overwatch right now.
I feel like Rivals is like...
Rivals is easier to play support.
I think.
I feel it.
Who's think that back?
Don't y'all remember the drag moon that had like 40k hours
of Necropara?
The thing about that is that you can leave Necropara open
AFK and get up the hours.
This guy is not leaving shit AFK.
He's He's playing, playing right now.
He's actively participating.
So it's not like he's...
It's not like he's opening an AFK.
It's like an active participant.
Let's not tarry.
They get to you.
So that's different compared to...
I think their Gen-G is worse.
Oh yeah, nice.
Relief.
Alright.
God, I wish I could aim better.
I mean, I could do like actual aim training for Kiriko.
But I've never done that for anything before, for any FPS
game.
And I don't know if I want to change now.
What?
Why did I TP in front?
Oh, they're just playing Lucio.
Yeah, oh my god.
I thought I'd be in the back.
That was mad bad.
Oh shit.
Aw.
Damn, unlucky.
I was gonna...
do that really I hit something oh my god that was a headshot
too that was a headshot oh
fuck okay whoops oh here for the Lucio all right I'm just
Mercy?
All right.
What was he before, Mercy?
I'm just surprised.
Why is this mad?
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Why is this mad on Murphy?
All right.
Please, please, don't shoot him.
Shoot him for the love of God.
Shoot him.
we lost to I don't even know how we lost to I mean that's
okay I mean okay keep pushing keep pushing I got it a little
bit further I got it a little further it works though oh
that's not good I didn't
Where the fuck did the gangl came from?
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh, that's also unlucky.
You know what?
That's alright.
The water kills.
Oh,
two kills, though.
Two kills.
Alright, guys.
I'm coming back.
He is the...
So, I'll bring it back.
I was so, I, like, what could he go to that?
Does he, I don't know if Azaria is all, which is a little
bit of a concern.
Might, would they be okay?
They should be fine.
Okay, that actually should have hit, so I'm sorry.
I don't know why that didn't hit.
Bye, soldier.
Goodbye, soldier.
Whoa!
Hello.
Hello again.
Oh.
That's unlucky.
Oh my god, he's so low.
Where did he go?
That was my bad.
I lost him.
I lost again.
Oh no, I...
Alright, it's 5.
I don't think I need...
Okay, I'll use it now.
I didn't think I had to use it, but I got scared.
Oh my god, that Lucio's won.
I got really scared.
I don't know if I should have used that.
No!
Oh, fuck.
I fucked up.
Oh, I was not supposed to grab that.
You jump in, I go on with you.
Oh my god.
On a run.
That sucks.
I fucked up.
It was supposed to be the right one.
Our Genji also fucked up.
I pressed Alt and then I was gonna do right and then I had
to hit.
I had to shoot someone.
That's bad.
Oh.
Give her a little bit of in.
Don't let them push it any farther.
Guys, we can't let them push it.
Alright.
Sorry, one.
No bubbles, no bubbles.
It's okay.
Because the movement is just so good.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're just gonna make do with it.
We're gonna make do with what we have.
Two- I- fucking- I hate.
Just tell me I have some of it.
TP too.
I do.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, thank god I did.
Oh, what's- Oh my god, it was so close.
Okay, whoever their Mercy player is, they don't know what to
play.
They're so confused Are they still fighting that Genji?
Come on, Gengu, you got this!
Come on, Gengu!
He lost the 1v1!
I just didn't expect them to leave.
it you know I didn't expect him to lose he lost the 1v1 how
did he lose the 1v1
how how did he lose it he had heals that Genshi didn't even
have oh my god I think he No, 100% our Genji is the worst
get the I'm our Genji is getting Genji diff not gonna lie
No, 100% for sure our Genji is getting diff No
Our Genji is about to get diffed again
Mean shit I didn't want to use it because I knew
All right, we just gotta regroup Last fight, last fight.
They use Blade.
I have my ult.
Just no one dies.
Genji and Kiri ult.
Next fight.
We use those two.
We win.
Never mind.
We just won.
GG.
All right.
Just use your ult.
Come on.
Just this Lucio.
Guys, there we go.
There we go.
See, it's that easy.
This is so...
Yay!
Look at that.
I had restraint.
I didn't use my...
Look at that.
We had ulted.
No, I think...
Better Genji got better play.
Their Genji was a lot better.
Literally the fact that like...
I healed...
It's okay, you tried.
I healed him.
I came over to that 1v1, healed him, left him, and he still
lost.
I was like, how do you lose that?
How the fuck?
You had a chance.
I...
He had no healers.
You even got like a fucking plus one heal.
That's insane.
That was actually insane.
Oh my god.
I'm just glad.
I'm glad we...
I'm glad we figured it out.
we're positive at the moment we're plus plus elo so
we are winning guys i don't know about the gm part though i
i don't know about that but
but we are winning i got disassociate though guys i give me
a sec i got it i got disassociate a little bit
know i'm just happy we're positive it took us six hours but
i got masters one back guys wait how many games i have to
win now i need my brain has to be on cool it out i need like
three wins i think let's see where is it challenges i don't
know is it here a lifetime is it lifetime there you go okay
i would lie it was a hot now i need 150 guys we're almost
there because we're almost there I just need to win 100 by
the time I win 150 games I'd be top 500 I mean I'm very
tenacious guys by the time then I'll unlock it it's so
stupid it's so 750 for streamer mode I guess they don't they
want to make sure like you know for hackers and stuff you
know it had like i get it they want to make sure like
hackers don't abuse streamer mode but like come on i'm a
streamer i but but i'm a streamer though
all right i highly recommend john's carpenter toxic commando
if you're looking for a four-player go out game got it
myself and it's really fun only for 40 dollars thank you
super chat thank you Is that the one that just came out that
was in Game Awards?
Oh, yeah, it's this.
It's like Left 4 Dead, basically.
I don't know if it's good.
Oh, is it good?
I mean, it has a...
Ooh, it has a 4.9.
I remember the trailer fucking sucked, though.
I remember everyone was talking shit because of the trailer.
Oh, apparently there's...
You can't play repeatedly.
Apparently.
I'm reading the reviews.
It's like, wait, can I play Elari?
Can... Can I play Elari with Weeing?
Or is it bad heals?
Because I don't remember.
It's good?
Let's go!
Boom!
Okay, I don't know why I needed it to be here, but...
Oh god.
My pylon was almost dead.
Doesn't see my pylon, though.
It's in the sky.
Boom!
Alright, there's no way he sees that.
Oh, he saw it.
He broke my pylon?
They broke my pylon?
Oh, shit.
All right, I might have to swap.
That's not fair.
Why can't you play?
Wait, what the fuck did he break my pylon?
Don't worry.
There's no way they see this pylon.
Where's my pylon?
Oh my god, there it is.
Don't worry.
How is he gonna see?
He saw it.
He saw it, but it's okay.
There we go.
See?
It's okay.
Look at that.
my god please tell me what guys it's 8.6 oh my god please
i'm coming over right now my pylon is still alive oh run run
run road i don't think he's running i don't think he ran
We're fine.
Get that pylon!
The truck pylon!
I'm gonna swap up at Lari.
I don't think...
Actually?
Unless...
I think it's fine.
They don't see my pylon.
There's no way they see it.
Okay, wait.
Don't worry.
The ground pylon.
Pylon.
Oh shit.
The ground pylon's got you!
There we go, there we go.
Now that's a good ass pylon.
Okay, wait, wait, no!
He destroyed it.
Okay.
There you go.
He's doing his job.
I'm so good at pylon placements guys Wait, wait You're not
expecting this
My pylon No No
I'm so fucking good Oh, I'm blessed
My pylons!
My beautiful pylons!
Oh, you do.
You
have a girl on your teeth.
My pylons!
Stop!
That's messed up.
Don't worry, I got you.
Alright.
Well, not anymore.
There's a woman?
Who?
Alright.
Come on,
these people are getting smarter about pylons now.
Christ, what happened to me?
like oh my god oh my god what happened to me hey guys hey
guys we really need help back here hey guys there's a
there's a diva
i just was not expecting that diva to fucking run in
i was like we should be fine i should swap but after my up
Oh Bye Wu Yang Wu Yang Yeah Okay, Wu Yang Okay, Wu Yang
Reforce the tide
All right Oh my god, we're so fucking dead my pylon okay
look that's awkward that's awkward i wanted to swap i wanted
to swap i wanted to swap i wanted to swap i what guys i
wanted to swap i wanted to swap and i'm gonna be a
Holy fuck I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to do.
I can't swap
It won't let me swap All right, sorry for it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's a pile on it.
Why are you with um Look I I won't play Lari for defense.
That's for sure
I'll go I'll go Kyrie
Badoof what do you mean Cosmo thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you I do bonus healing thank you super chat
thank you thank you it is like the entire kit for Ilari like
her only way to heal is literally the it's literally I do
shoot her I do do that I do Her pylon.
If her pylon's gone, it's just...
There's nothing you could do.
Follow the rules, and we won't have a problem.
No, that diva is a problem, though.
Damn twinked.
Alright.
What?
No one shoots the...
Even though, I will agree.
It was just me and the support and the work.
It's the...
Okay, the Widow's guy.
What?
Oh my god, he came from nowhere.
It's fine, we have Wu Yang.
Let's get back to it.
It's okay.
If he's scared of women so much, how is he...
Oh, whoa.
Goodbye.
How is he able to confront women?
Okay, this guy's...
That's my bad.
I didn't know where the fuck that came from.
I don't think he's gonna live.
I'm just gonna leave now.
Oh, we lost first point.
I mean, we can still grab...
Never mind, I was gonna say.
I wish I could play life.
I wish I could play Lari.
There's an enemy here.
There's a diva over there.
Alright, just in case, I don't, cause I don't, yeah, I don't
feel that Lari's just gonna.
We like, shoot that, a Lari that's over there?
Like, Genji.
Genji, just fucking...
Bro, what the fuck?
And he just fucking confronts the lorry over there.
He's just free-shodding for free.
Like, why are you so scared?
Why do I need help?
Oh, I help.
How is that?
That Genshin is so scared of that lorry.
Nice.
All right.
Fucking it.
Hello.
I might definitely need some help.
I...
Everyone, I...
That Elari?
I wish I was that Elari.
Nobody contested this Elari.
Why can't that be me?
There we go.
Oh my god, I swear to...
Oh my, I pressed E.
I pressed E.
I spammed that shit.
I spammed it.
I heard it.
I heard it and I spammed it.
Oh my god, I keep pressing G.
I keep pressing G instead of F.
Let me balance you out.
Where's the bomb gonna...
Alright, we should be fine here, eh?
Oh my god, please.
Okay, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
We're so fine.
That Diva has barely died, but we're okay.
Oh my god, I swear to God.
That Diva is like...
is living forever right now.
There we go.
All right, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, oh no, that's all right.
We don't have to all three minutes of this.
Let's go three.
Oh, whoa three One death and it's over.
Let's fucking go That's how I like it.
Hey, nice Okay, that was scary that was scary actually that
was very scary that could have been oh my god why what are
you doing over there i'll be back here now as the only
support over there
as the only support over here i'll be i'll be over here oh
my god literally stood up and got this oh thank god okay
thank god i didn't even realize I did not see the junk rat
there.
Alright, two more minutes of this.
Let's go.
Yay!
Oh no.
Oh no, he's going for picks now.
I don't want to beat this.
That's not way enough.
Every time!
Oh my god!
got every time okay it's fine it's fine it's fine we have at
movements at the movement one
it's fine oh my
it's okay
it's you and me dark i'm not peeking this but it's you and
me okay all right it's you and me Junker at all.
Ty.
We're dead.
Oh, he's dead!
Why?
Why would you pick Widow?
Oh my god, I can't even do anything.
Why?
You know he has a widow!
Your heels don't need a widow!
Our Wu Yang doesn't need a worry about widow!
Oh my god.
He was...
He literally...
He just had to, like, not peek.
He just had to not look.
That was a reversal!
There's no way.
That was rough.
That would have...
Like, he literally, all he had to do was, like, just wait.
That's all he had to do.
I don't understand why.
It's okay.
Oh, it's so hot in my room.
I really need laundry.
I got my, like...
Because in Japan, I brought my, like...
what is it called summer pajamas so like I need to wash now
I'm wearing my winter pajamas right now and it's hot as fuck
in my room because it's a sauna
Diva Vendetta and I don't know I don't know I just want to
ban Diva Vendetta wait okay yeah what uh apparently our ash
last game was cheating oh i should abandon another character
he was asked if he's cheating our ash which he was so i just
got dm'd by scared of girl and apparently they're just
they're just locking through walls and just like walking
around like a like a literal drone damn our ash was pretty
garbage oh look the rank 33 Was this a champ lobby?
Oh wait, I'll do it.
That guy has 288 chronically online.
It's so bad for cheats too.
Ranked 33 Grandmaster 5.
This guy has been not, he has not stopped.
Do 191 and 118?
Holy.
Yeah.
That Ash was garbage.
but this guy I don't want to play Kiri he this person has a
Kiri player I saw his thing good enough I literally saw his
shit you play Kiri I guess I'll play Lucio after this what
the fuck it yo got this guy get him get him get him where
did he come from actually wait their team fucking backed up
after that's funny can i put this up here oh yes i can
the ensue was like nah
Okay, that's not on me.
It's not on me to keep up.
Some more.
Okay, that's...
That's unfortunate.
Okay.
Alright, that's unfortunate.
It's okay.
We gotta push pretty.
Oh, no.
And they can push back pretty far, too.
Wee!
All right, go Kiri after this.
Oh, he's running away.
And he ran.
Oh, nice.
Hey, my thing is still here.
Ha ha ha!
What the fuck?
That's crazy.
Okay, this Ryan, we gotta avoid this Ryan.
This Ryan might be an inter.
This Ryan is not, like, not very inspiring, I will say.
Where's my BAP?
Yeah, my BAP is just gonna...
Oh.
I'll just leave.
I think I'll be fine.
I hope I hit him.
someone he pooped them away so I'm a boy they get instant
respawn fuck they all get instant respawn I was gonna say I
hope I hope he fucking I hit somebody there cuz like he
pooped everybody away from me no hey my back my oh oh oh the
pylon isn't there no more Never mind.
Oh, I'm serene.
Oh, no, never mind.
Yeah, I'm coming back very slowly.
Your bop, you're sleeker.
Don't worry, I got you.
Whoa.
It's a, I can!
It's five.
It's fine.
Bring it back.
I'm bringing it back.
There we go.
There you go.
We're gaming.
Stay near my pylon, everybody.
I'm escorting.
Don't worry.
I got the escort.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That's not me.
He might be fucked, though.
He might be fucked up.
Like, does he know?
oh fuck oh fuck i messed up
all right it's okay it's okay everything is fine
all right i think we should have just all died maybe we
haven't baffled at all that's not like this year for him
that's what i've noticed i've noticed that we have not
baffled
That was a good flick by me, I will say.
If I could, I-
There we go, there we go.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
There you go.
Skypylon!
I'll push this.
And then maybe this time we'll ult.
I believe in the ult.
No, I'm scared.
I think he's going to solo shatter me again.
Why did you bump it?
Also, where the fuck is your BAP ult?
How long have we been holding this ult for?
He's literally running a no-ult challenge.
This man is running a no-ult challenge right now.
I've not seen a single BAP ult from this man.
Oh my god, he's done it.
I blocked it.
he's actually done it oh my lord
he's done it that was like the first alt boom is it healing
i mean oh it does does it no
is that oh he cleansed it They'll
be fine.
They'll be fine.
Look, I made them use cleanse.
Guys, I made them use cleanse.
Okay?
Look, I might not know how to use...
I might still not know how to use theirs.
But I damn well...
I know how to use the Pylinder.
Get him back.
Oh no, not a winch gun.
Yeah, I think I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna die on point.
Fuck it.
There's no way I live that long.
There's...
Okay, I'm fine with that.
I'm fine with living that long.
I have been enjoying Overwatch a lot.
I'm learning a lot, too.
Oh, shit.
it whoa are you guys okay over there nope we'll leave yeah
bye I think we gotta see about Winston okay
okay it's fine it's fine it's
fine Yeah, I shatter.
It's okay.
My pylon...
Oh, I'm gonna be over here now.
Repositioning pylon!
What is she gonna do?
Is she gonna...
Pylon!
Oh my god, he took my pylon away.
Oh my god.
God, he's getting repositioning Pylon.
There we go.
Look at that.
I repositioned the Pylon.
They'll never expect it.
When in doubt.
Pylon out.
Another Baptiste song.
Holy shit.
Say it ain't so.
I've never seen it before in my life.
Doki, your pile is too big.
The enemy team is getting jealous.
Old chart.
See you in the super chat.
Thank you.
I go get salad.
Let me see how much...
Wait, how do I check?
Is it history?
Oh my god, this...
I mean, this part is nice.
How much did I...
What was it?
healing.
72% pylon uptime percentage.
That's pretty good.
Look at that.
Yes.
My pylon was up on that wall.
72% of the time.
I know.
I'm not good.
I'm going to continue to construct additional pylons.
Select your hero
choose heroes to ban
all right here we go vendetta diva
and i don't know surely they don't we won't have a third
random ban right Oh, fuck.
It's all right.
I'm just having fun.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Does that say cocaine ape?
The fuck?
All right.
I'm ready.
Who's that under the teacher's pet?
Cocaine ape.
I still...
feel i will say though um i feel marvel rivals have have
better names i feel i think marvel rivals names are much
better than they're more funny overwatch okay overwatch i
think overwatch they actually they make you change your
names if it's too funny and so i told you guys gamers rise
up out of gamers rise up tag that got name changed by like
blizzard when was like um here's a free name tag change
please change your name we get yeah but in rivals you can
get wild
pylon all right they they will shoot pylons they they will
shoot pylons um i might have to Nothing to that.
Wait, unless I put it up.
Here!
They're shooting my pylons.
They're actually shooting my pylons.
This is bad.
You might shoot my pylons, but my team will shoot you.
Okay, so this is a little awkward, because it looks like
they do shoot.
They do shoot pylons.
It was a little awkward for me.
Surely they won't shoot.
shoot this, right?
Man, I'm gonna break.
Oh, fuck!
Alright, I definitely need a swap, though.
I have to swap.
I don't think I can sustain.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's okay.
My pylon's still alive.
It's still... No, alright.
I'm swapping.
There's just no point.
Alright, here we go.
I'm not They're all finding it
It's fine We're on meta now Now we're on meta We have speed
boost Even better
Oh my god Maybe I'm just gonna Oh I don't love that Oh
Oh no.
I know.
Yeah, I love playing Overwatch.
Oh my god.
There you go.
I don't understand.
How come they have eyes?
Don't understand.
How do they have eyes?
How do they see what you can't see?
Yay!
All right, well, GG.
Free.
win free win wait that was their tank too okay yeah that's
yeah i take those no i'll cap it you don't need speed there
you go yay free low
yippee i love free low yeah speed boost for lucio is a lot
more viable now Yay, Frido!
Frido!
Yay!
I deserve Frido!
Alright, I'll give you... I'll give you amps just because
you asked very nicely.
He didn't ask, but like, in my head.
I'm sorry.
What's he gonna do?
These guys are fucked.
Yeah, let's go.
have that.
Yippee!
The worst part about for, I think they should have a
surrender button in Overwatch, like, rivals.
Because they have to sit through all of this.
You know?
Like, they can't just... I mean, they could leave, I guess.
But still, it'd be easier to just be able to surrender.
They're gonna leave, yeah?
Please leave.
Oh.
Oh my god, where is he?
Where is he?
Let's see, I got him.
Oh,
why are you so facing me for?
Wait, where's the point?
Oh, the point is all the way there.
All right, here you go.
Oh, they left, thank god.
Yay!
Please leave.
Oh it's just a DPS.
It's literally just a DPS.
They're still here.
Please leave.
Oh it's Anna and Gengel.
Tank left because I'm on Genji.
Goodbye, I need my stats.
And second DPS asks how much I weigh.
How much and left.
Big man.
Damn.
Also, what's your weight?
Yeah, Lucia win!
Yay!
Look at that.
I'm not watched.
I won on Lucia.
I won there.
If he was really, if he is a big man, could have carried his
entire team.
Wait, not length.
Oh, Overwatch.
Oh.
Oh, look at that.
See, I don't forget the OG.
Yay!
Wait, that's a lot.
Oh, my God.
That's a lot, you know.
Poor guy.
All he wanted to do was play Genji.
All right, back to opening loot boxes.
How would I get it?
Get two more games.
ew what's this oh it's just name card i'm a professional
where are my skins more name cards come on
oh oh my god really
the fucking course the back to back mercy skinned a fucking
back to back
There's 30 plus characters, and yet somehow I still get two
Mercy skins.
Select your hero.
Choose hero bands.
Oh my god.
I just saw a tweet of this.
Is this a pro player?
Oh my god, that's crazy.
I saw... There's the tweet of this guy.
an apex in apex where his girlfriend is giving birth and
he's out there playing apex legends i can't tell if this is
real i can't our photos shall we this
is this at grok is this real is this real at grok
respect the grad he's playing pred lobbies i carry my
burdens alone there's no way that's real photoshop right it
was boring yeah no way where's his headphones yeah oh yeah
dark is the cheater what's he do he's just a drone he just
aim hacks no that's like the worst bro no but he but he's
better than be like oh wait i don't think i have enough
heals for this
let's put them on the spot oh wait We don't have enough hits
for this.
Oh, okay.
I thought he was swapped.
I'm not going to lie.
I thought he would swap.
Okay.
Cheater down.
Good job.
Oh my god, you can stick it on the...
Oh wait, that's not the ceiling.
There you go.
Alright.
There's no way he'll aim hack my pylons, right?
Okay.
She's so bodied for a cheater.
I didn't like he was actually doing so bad.
Man.
Where is he?
Oh my god I have to like be so focused because I don't want
lose to a hacker.
I have to like make sure my positioning is not ass.
Oh nice.
put it here for now.
All right.
My pylons still here.
Constructing additional pylons still.
Bro, that guy is such an ass cheater.
Like he actually is.
No!
My pylons!
He ate boss pylons!
I didn't think it was possible!
Oh.
I didn't know it was possible!
I didn't...
He could be my boss!
I didn't know he could do that!
Oh no, my poor guy!
Okay, I actually have to...
I'm actually have to swap now.
I was going to swap earlier, but then I got a little too
greedy.
All right.
It's five.
Healing Pylon is out again.
All right.
Oh my god.
He's such a blatant cheater.
okay it's okay i'm here there's like one hp oh i'm one oh
wait you're one hp
it's your one hp oh my god i should have kept the pilot
okay oh that bear has all and i'm scared What?
I need to farm this fast so I can...
Please, please, please.
Oh, he did.
Oh, he was so low, I'm so sad.
So far as one, far one, far one.
He is.
But who's gonna save me?
You have to touch Lucia!
What do you mean?
Wait!
Hold on.
I'm doing an ungodly amount.
Stellar, you might need to swap.
I don't know what the hell your character is going to do in
that combo.
Oh my god.
I think me as Elari was doing more.
It was actually doing more.
Honestly.
Honestly, me as...
Okay.
where we were i was gonna say me as a lara was doing more
than what the was going on with my team
dude the moment he swapped the cast he started aimbotting my
pylons like what is wrong what's wrong with him what's the
freaking freak he actually aimbotted my pylons that's crazy
i didn't even know that was possible
Oh, that's not good.
What is wrong with him?
Like, what?
Far low.
Super low.
1 HP.
Still 1 HP.
Oh, that's a blessing.
Oh my god, I don't think we're winning this.
I don't think we're winning this right now.
Wait, if we report him for cheating and he gets banned, I
get my Elo back.
That's how it goes.
Oh, okay, well...
Guys, I don't think we're winning this.
I really don't think so.
We were actually doing better with... We were actually doing
better with Eli.
That's actually crazy.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
You got it.
No, you got it.
He's got it.
There's a one.
One each of you.
Oh, he wins.
Okay, we got it.
I don't know.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
I'm okay.
Do we need this?
Oh, I'm talking to you.
I'm okay right now all right we got a we got all right we
got 91% and we got the point back we got it we did it we did
it yeah he's like 50
Jesus Christ
Where's my...
No!
I mean, you got it.
Oh, never mind.
What is going on?
What the fuck is going on?
This is a circus right now.
Guys, What is the circus?
I'm trying.
Here we go.
We got him.
Raid boss down.
Alright.
One more fight.
I don't know.
We have enough ult for this last fight, though.
Yes, castle.
Yes, winter and all.
The Winston all is what I'm most afraid.
Oh, and that too, I guess.
Come on.
Please, you gotta live for me.
You gotta live for me.
Wait, our monkey will live for us.
Guys.
I'm coming back.
Oh my god, double Winston.
Double Winston.
of the century right now that's what you mean by the way i
got the rain double wind turn this is it right all right
into a cheater guys okay here we go two monkeys when it's
better than one monkey two monkeys if any of you saw it but
that that creed like while we were all stacked up where
white room was he was just behind us shooting us and then
walked into my bowl and we That's crazy.
That's crazy.
This is possible.
Here we go.
Monkey together, shrog.
Apes together, shrog!
Their monkey is doing more than the fucking hacker is
actually sad.
Alright.
Is he using speech boost first?
Yeah, he does.
Alright.
And then...
And then we have extra extra speed.
There's no suzu for 10 seconds.
Let's hope we don't need it.
Whoa.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
It's okay.
What?
Oh my god.
Why?
That was Bullshit, that's actually bullshit.
Holy fuck.
I'm so scared.
Oh
my god, he got all so fast.
That's good.
With the monkey!
Monkey, where?
where okay monkey there oh my god cast here too there we go
oh my god okay hackers not on bastion that's good that's
good I got scared that the hacker was on bastion I got a
little scared there wait
wait it's possible No luck.
Hey, where's my Emory?
There he is.
Okay, no, he was one!
Yes!
It's okay!
It's oh no!
No!
It's okay.
Yes!
We're so back!
from that there you go there you go okay okay
okay throwing the first round i had to lock in it's so over
we're so back it's so over we're so back it's all right man
whoa all right that is you break from me and oh i can't do i
can do more and more in fact in in but also
also mean guy
the that cheater has to be dirt ring pro this guy he has the
aim just doesn't know what to do with it um Cosmo thank you
super chat thank you thank you um next to you super chat
thank you thank you that reminds me of the of the account oh
what does uh they give a super chat next seat thank you
thank you you hear my feelings oh not my feeling here are my
teammates feelings uh you didn't hurt my feeling what's my
challenger score right now stupid ass challenger score thing
oh here you go it is a thousand seven hundred i'm getting
there three more k three k more
oh it's scared of girl it's back
how are you masters i don't know as in like am i bad or good
how are you masters all right hear me out the dark that dark
guy the the guy named dark yes god he's terrible he was
cheating bro he was just he's just cheating he's a drone
like exactly what you told me i bro you should have known
just based on the i watched the first kill cams and like he
wasn't like he wasn't like aim body like hard blocking but
like i would literally watch him just stare into a wall
right at me i'm like what is going on i didn't know he did
that yes bro like the first couple kill cams i'm like and
i'm telling my team i'm like guys i don't know about this
this dark guy oh and then like all right here we go i'm like
what is happening
that he should refund his cheat and he told me to take a oh
oh the photo next to the use super chat thank you oh is diva
open i wasn't banning anything what that means unlucky
that's all you needed to hear bro i didn't ban anything so
that's pretty awkward it's it's just hilarious that every
every person who hacks are always so aggressive because
that's like their defense mechanism bro
just say ty like i played junk rats like what do you mean
back to the back to constructing additional pylons my home
turf i saw you a little fucking michael kobe always going on
the fucking eric dunking on the far off like what was i
expecting more from you are you actually cheating boom right
this is it i'm honestly curious what what a cheating junk
rat looks like does the cheating junk rat even work oh my
god yeah my cast my cast might be shooting okay that's the
saddest part i headshot it he's off of tracer he's off of
tracer now no no no no
Why do they have to increase fucking HP pools, man?
Only one shot fucking cast.
This is so...
You keep breaking my pylon, what do I do?
That's fucking... I can aim!
You want me to bubble you?
If you go in?
I'm gonna do it.
There's just a cast there.
I mean, I can just play Widow, right?
They just flick.
You don't see it, right?
You got all the aim like that?
Oh, we're going to find out.
I am a jump start player.
All right.
That hurt, right?
You don't know.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
They beat?
Okay.
Catch on Zarya.
You got the Pylod?
Walking on Zarya.
himself sorry i have the retreat oh i'm so oh i'm leaving oh
my god he clicked q what that's crazy it's so scary well
this guy in particular honestly barry a headshot
i took away he's gonna die here to a tracer what the fuck oh
my god this is not fair
I'm so sick of this Moira oh I've got my big alright this is
fine this is fine you know what good trade everyone let's
walk up it's fine it is fine guys boom constructed
additional my god this guy has That's awkward.
There you go.
Okay, we're cheating.
Like you said.
Look at that.
Look at that!
The other Moira.
She fucking lived through it.
She actually lived through it through my 100 charge Zarya
needs.
Are you serious?
How is he still alive?
I got stuck.
Okay, she's gonna jump.
I win these.
Where's that Tracy?
Reach out.
Oh, whoa!
Okay, that was a sick shot.
That was a shot.
Boom, right here.
There's no way he sees the pylon here.
Alright, this is gonna work.
He's so scared every time.
He's so scared.
Absolutely bamboo.
That tracier doesn't I do not want to fight me.
Bro, every time that tracer sees me and fucking leaves, he's
so fucking scared.
That's right, little baby.
It's PTSD.
Every time I one-shot it.
We got that PTSD right now, mind-controlled, little trauma.
Not just head to head at the double head you do twice
Okay his that tracer is so bad.
He doesn't know how to blink prop like blink in a confusing
way So he's so predictable He's very predictable like to
figure out very Genshin impacty What the
What?
My pylon!
Oh, the heart's pumping!
Oh, I need help, I need help, I need help, I need help,
ASAP.
Oh my god, never mind.
I just feel like a sleeping.
I'm spamming in the room.
Forgot, I'm Malga.
There you go.
I'm over tuned to balls right now.
The only issue is if she sucks me and then I won't be
laughing no more.
The moment she sucks me, I won't be laughing.
As soon as Viva becomes irrelevant, this character is gonna
just skyrocket and playtime.
that's never gonna happen did he actually okay no did your
love their money makers too much
all right
oh shit bro you're crazy for that
wait that cast that moron cast were so scared of me not the
sleep i just noticed that do i see that cast kept running
away from me because i kept headshotting all right come over
here i'm like yeah that's right sir get your ultimate ready
oh it's
supposed to like keep you in right yeah they don't know the
additional pylons boy i don't have okay wait wait wait wait
wait i forgot maugas old doesn't give you unlimited ammo
anymore that's right okay my pylons gone though
It's okay.
Cat.
Boom!
It's okay.
Nothing to worry about.
No, they're on Diva.
Is he gonna be okay?
Yeah, he's gonna be okay.
Ah, where is
he?
Yo, where is he?
Hey,
we did it.
Dude, I love you.
I'm on your team.
I don't have to do anything and I just win.
I might be on an altercator.
That's great.
Yeah, but you lost to me, so...
Yeah, I had a cheater and he was ass, okay?
He was completely dog-sitting, stupid idiot.
Yeah, that guy was...
Damn.
Bye, Tracer.
He is glad.
Five, six!
Five to six open all loud.
Someone help him.
Oh my god, this is it?
Did they do it?
Yeah!
We did it!
We got the GM on stream!
Oh my god!
It was an uphill battle.
Plus 37 as...
Holy shit, I got so much from that.
I got like a...
I have a win streak right now.
Oh my god, let's go.
GG's.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we did it.
We actually got GMed, guys.
Yes.
Leave.
Gee, chat.
Go eat.
No, we're not sacrificing it.
I'm just happy to eat.
We were here.
I know we're now.
I just want to get it on stream.
I was surprised I was going to get it on stream, though.
I was surprised.
uh why are you still we did it boy that poor tracer i want
to know wait where's my do i have an it was it was oasis
right is this a poor tracer i didn't even fucking see him
there bro i think i think i'm a lorry player what was it
bro that adam doesn't even know i'm there thank you i just
heard the blink and was just like
that's crazy that's actually crazy oh i think it was super
chat thing it's time to play it's grind to play win what do
you mean i already like five tiers above the other top 500
players right now let's see where is it guys can't say that
to me guys you guys can't say that to me is this challenger
score bullshit guys yes look at look at this look at this
all the way diamond two you can't say that there is a
diamond two in top 500 just purely by the amount of hours he
plays there's we haven't this guy's diamond two in top 500
right now chat that's insane wild look at i'm literally i
could have been in top five i could have been here i could
have literally been here if we're not going by challenger
score i could be here right now i
no no they don't because it's challenger score challenger
score is there's no way he could get 5k points um in diamond
if he has a high win rate there's no way you actually have
to just keep playing you have to keep playing because every
game you win you win challenger score the higher rank you
are the more challenger score you can gain but technically
you can just keep playing and playing and playing until you
have enough challenger score it's just you just gotta keep
playing if i was in like a higher gm i could earn like 200
points per win and then like it's just we'll just be there
just he has no life it exactly just play every day and then
you can get it i play for three days oh wait not practice
range i play for three days and already have a challenger
score of almost 2k chat of almost 2 000 oh my god you can
tell that i started giving up on kiriko you can tell you see
me trying to figure it out and being like all right all
right here we go all right i was like fuck this i'm just
playing lorry on her.
I'm trying so hard to figure her out.
I just came up.
I was like, I know my strength.
Sparrow, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just got here at the ending of the match.
But congratulations.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I get to actually defend myself by shooting.
My shots actually hit.
But yes, look, see, I got 2,000 in three days from masters
to gm but apparently gm you get even more challenger scores
uh thanks a lot i really appreciate it holy wait i actually
want to see this tracer's pov i want to see the tracer's pov
there or is it game reports history what was that like for
her income straight i want to know all right where is he we
know it's pirate Wait, dude, they swapped tracers.
Oh my god, yeah, they swapped tracers.
This guy knew it was over.
Wait, they swapped tracers.
He was like, I'm not fucking...
Because it wasn't him before.
It's me and Cass.
Me and Cass.
And then the other one learned why.
We both literally just...
And then, alright, and then, alright, then...
Pirates swapped the tracer after.
When does he swap the tracer?
Oh, here.
And he's like, you know, I'll try one step.
Alright, I don't even know if I got a shot.
I think this was a new tracer.
Yeah, this is the new tracer.
You're like, I don't think you should play tracer.
Here we go.
That's like, you want to go again?
He's so lucky.
He's so beautiful.
He's like, bro.
He's so lucky.
They won that fight because we were down three.
That was crazy.
That's so funny.
And I never saw this tracer again.
I never saw him again after that.
He's so cautious.
I literally, every time he looked at me, I just shot him.
He was so scared.
He never peeked me after that.
Do you guys notice we haven't seen a tracer in so long?
He never peeked me.
He only showed up in...
He's so cautious as a tracer.
And he's spotted, then he's dead.
Bro, what the...
Fuck is this guy is so bad at tracer.
Holy shit
They're so scared Didn't want to fucking do these these
tracer you're supposed to flake what are you doing?
What the fuck are you doing?
Bro is so lost One shot and he leaves
Alright, where is he?
Where am I?
I mean, there Elari seems to be pretty good too.
Oh, I shot him there.
I caught him there.
Come on.
Oh yeah, and then that's not fair.
And then the other.
Alright, this last shot.
I won't look at the last shot.
It's right here, right?
This one was funny as hell.
It was this one was so funny.
fucking stupid.
I literally heard a blink and just instaed fucking blick.
Look, I've never seen a tracer play so much like a pussy.
This tracer plays like a goddamn pussy.
I don't think this is his main.
I really don't.
This is the most...
He's so passive.
He actually is so passive.
Bro, that's okay, I would have to say, I have to pat myself
on the back there because that the flake was insane.
That flake was actually really good for me.
Right there.
I literally heard the flake and just instant flicked it.
Because there's like right here.
Holy fuck i need to look no what's this guy's elo what does
he actually play
oh my god what that's so much easier kill tracer too as
elari is so much easier like it's so easy to hit these guys
all right elari oh wait that's me i'm elari is your oh i'll
never know i'll never know what about you you're the one
that insta swapped up He's a top 500 Doom player, though.
I like how we can even see, like, what rank he is as a top
500 Doom player.
Oh, my God.
This guy doesn't even play DPS.
What the fuck?
This guy doesn't even...
I mean, yeah, I can tell.
This guy...
Oh, my God.
This is too...
That was fun, though.
That was fun.
I'm enjoying the gray.
I'm glad we were able to climb.
the GM on stream.
We, see you guys, it looked bad at first, but then we turned
it around, chat.
We turned it, it looked bad at first.
It looked really bad at first, guys.
It really did look really, really bad at first, but then we
made it.
We made it, everyone.
Yeah, we, we fucking, we climbed our way out of it.
We got it on stream.
oh that's fun that's fun tomorrow we have an afternoon
stream all hell the power of it like what is my the sr oh 3
900 rating i mean i'm having a lot of fun with her i just
know she's very situation i'm like forcing elari right now
because like she's technically not hard meta she's like
situational but i'm like every situation is elari time uh to
me right now i'm like she might she's situational but every
situation is illari
because she's fun i have so much fun um playing her yeah not
situational for you i mean i do swap out when it's when they
see where my i think like the higher elo i get though the
more they'll actually see my um the more they'll actually
see where the fuck i place the moment they know where my
pylons is when i swap off elari because there's no point
yeah it turns out clicking hits never gets out of style
exactly exactly uh it's nice game back into streaming and
playing overwatch for you guys uh i play a lot off stream
obviously so um it was just fun to just you know grind the
game again um um well so i had a fun time i had fun week
week Basically, I mean, yesterday I talked to Sachi and then
she gave me the lore dump of her gotcha her gotcha life
scene behind but she was a famous anime for those who didn't
know she was a before gotcha life thing.
I mean even after she was a famous animation meme artist.
So like she had a lot of animation meme videos back then
that went super viral and stuff like that.
So and then and then that's how gotcha life found out about
her because the creator of gotcha life was like i really
love watching your animation memes and i really love your
art and they're like yeah and cover videos and music too um
her animation memes and covered music videos and the gotcha
life guy was like i really love your stuff uh can i have you
in your game and now she's in gotcha life and her person
just literally if you find her in gotcha life it's just
always talking about whale memes like not memes are whale
facts it's just all whale facts i thought it was really
funny when me yeah um and then but yeah um yes you she got a
lot of her subscribers from her animation memes and her um
and her cover videos and then and then the children found
her through gotcha life and she got even more subscribers uh
but it was really cool it was really funny i was just like
oh my god You mean that game?
That game?
I don't even know how to explain gotcha life.
I've never even played it.
I just know a lot of children really like it.
Yeah.
But it was fun to go back to.
When to go back to the Overwatch too.
Just vibing.
Anyway, tomorrow.
Tomorrow we're going to have retro rewind story simulator at
1230 p.m.
It's time to go back to the simulator.
Time to go back into simulation.
I want to drag her back into Overwatch.
I keep telling her to come back to Overwatch.
She's been really busy, though.
I keep telling her.
I was like, come back to Overwatch.
It's really fun, I swear.
And I'm like tempting her every day.
I'm like, come back.
Not every day, but every time we message each other.
I'm like, you should come back to Overwatch.
I swear, it's really fun.
I...
That's so cute.
and she's like okay okay when when i have time um and seven
thank you the super chat thank you thank you thanks for a
fun stream doki and super gomer thank you for the super chat
thank you thank i'm glad you guys enjoyed it i'm glad we
were able to climb in the end you know and i carried some
games i did carry some games i did carry some games i just
existed but some the larry games i definitely carried chat i
definitely okay not all of them but like i would say 80 of
the larry did stuff um hey guys as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check it up and move around to get that
blood flow and you stay up for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye